[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
hey everybody yeah sandra you [ __ ]
funny man
hopefully this microphone is working
because it was off when i came on here
but it looks like it's working now yeah
right uh yeah every time it's almost
kind of like one minute before like i
always start the show and then sandra
comes in then i always see her
her new handle and it's like a [ __ ]
crack up what i forgot to bring down
mazinga
so go get him i'm gonna get my zanga
nobody's gonna get both
oh you get oh he needs the chair for it
that's what it is yeah
also happy birthday rusty 18 today holy
crap
i was 18 30 years ago
and i don't even remember but yeah
so uh hey everybody happy friday
look tom even put pants on yeah i put
pants on
and everyone's like wait normally he
doesn't well
my [ __ ] [ __ ] starts falling out
[Laughter]
yeah he's just sitting there naked as a
bird
yeah you can't see it though the camera
angles all right
put a mirror there for a few people
get all that gay money
you want all the gay money get all that
game money all the game money yeah
game money and straight money you can
spend it just gay money spends the same
as straight money
that's right yes hunters i don't think
i've ever seen tom's legs
he doesn't have any oh he's just a torso
and a head
yeah well it's just no i think he had
shorts on earlier though he had shorts
yeah he had shorts on
then he was like well i gotta dress up
for this [ __ ] yeah good go [ __ ]
full full uniform
are you trying to settle down that you
never settle down
when does that ever how i've never seen
you settle down whatever
i'm laughing at sandra's name i know i
was too like i said that's like
i saw it like a minute before we went on
close attention
doesn't have a dick on her shoulder yeah
she's panicking that you know of she's
paying close attention you better look
you never know
to to the lore of tom when a dick might
appear on your shoulders at any time
i know your name sandra i was [ __ ]
looking for you on facebook i can't tell
which one you are there's a lot of
people with that
with that last name you need to friend
me on facebook that should be [ __ ]
funny man
tj maniac says i'm not even putting
pants on for the next two days if i can
help it and i don't blame you yeah
maniac can just sit there in his damn
underwear i don't blame you nah man [ __ ]
it you want to make money put a jock
strap on
a leather job put that [ __ ] on live
stream
oh my god it's so early i'm already
beginning
yeah yeah yeah uh mr roboto says jenny
you can be forever 21
sure why not um i don't remember what it
was like to be 21 but i'll get out i
could try
uh and esther says love the shirt thank
you i don't wear this one all that often
i don't know why
i have so many t-shirts that i just like
i keep forgetting like the ones that i
have in there it's my clockwork
oh the clockwork one yeah my clockwork
orange one saunder says i'm boring on
social media no pictures nothing no
pictures nothing all right okay
yeah some people are all right that's
good enough then
as i saw with thomas put a face to this
[ __ ] that was gonna go creep on the page
yeah i had to put a face to this [ __ ]
see who it was
i don't ever do that i've never creeped
on anybody else's page
that's some good [ __ ] we gotta [ __ ]
hire her hire her as a writer
i know that is like really crazy [ __ ]
that i can say but she's playing off of
me she's just
she's underlining crazy [ __ ] that i did
but i really
well i like like what she plucks out
from your stream of consciousness
i forget it yeah i say it i forget it
yeah it's just the force you know
yeah this comes out it's demonic it's
demonic possession i yeah it is
yeah i i definitely think yeah i i
definitely
think you have a demon in there or maybe
two yeah at least
at least at least they say it they say
oh that's good you have an out when you
when you do something terrible and i've
never told
yeah probably yeah yeah mr abada says
tom settles eventually i don't know like
the drunker he gets he probably like
he's gonna be like
rampaging around especially because the
show
is about feral children yeah and i feel
like everybody
that has kids is like yeah tell me
something i don't know all kids are
feral
not really that we're talking about
something a completely different
different [ __ ]
hey man growing up [ __ ] my cousin
wesley was like dealing with a feral
child
oh he was uh deaf
and autistic and he learned sign
language late
so he was kind of feral you know what i
mean they didn't know what was wrong
with him until he was like six or seven
that was going back to seven see and
that's kind of like
what i want to get into a little bit
because i think the reason why but and
feral children that doesn't necessarily
mean like a kid that
like was in the forest and was raised by
animals although sometimes it does
it's basically just like any kid that
didn't have any human interaction for a
very significant part of their childhood
and hence didn't
uh develop in a way that a normal human
would
so sometimes and i kind of want to get
into this a little bit too like
sometimes some linguists are saying
that and this is it's still a theory but
it's still it's pretty solid
even though it's a little bit
controversial still um is that
there is a very definite window for
language acquisition
and if you don't get any language input
during that time period then you will
never you can learn
to communicate later like in other ways
sign language whatever
but you will never master a language
like the grammar
structure or anything like wesley never
never mastered grammar or structure or
anything
you know he learned like i said he
learned sign language way late yeah like
six or seven
and uh they didn't know what was wrong
with him he wouldn't make eye contact
with any adults he'd make eye contact
with me
because i wasn't asking anything of him
most adults were trying to test him and
make him do some contests they were
trying to figure out
what was wrong with him yeah but it was
uh he was deaf
deaf and autistic i think that i think
that the deafness
and everything was going on in the 70s
you know i mean the real primitive
the way they were trying to figure out
kids like kyle's child psychology and
everything
yeah in their the testing was terrible
even in california
so i think he be i think the deafness
and kind of like i want i don't want to
call it mistreatment but like medical
malpractice i think caused him to become
kind of like
autistic he didn't want anything to do
with the outside world really
but what he did master was mathematics
yeah by six or seven he was doing
algebra
yeah like he could do you know [ __ ]
advanced algebra
i think he could do trigonometry
eventually too by the time he was about
11 or 12.
i mean his math skills were just [ __ ]
insane because that was a language he
could understand
yeah but written stuff and like sign
language is real
crude basic you know that's pretty
common right with people on the spectrum
yeah you would like uh you could use
sign language
once he knew sign language no matter
what you signed or wrote down
he'd interpret it like maybe one out of
five different ways
and you don't realize that you can
interpret uh you know
a sentence in a bunch of different ways
but when you're autistic or
don't have good language skills you
could interpret a sentence in about five
like four different ways
yeah we don't have a math mastery of
tense
yeah and articles sometimes [ __ ] [ __ ]
them up and
plurals it just like i said there's a
certain window you're supposed to
learn yeah and like i said that's kind
of one of the things that
um even though feral children haven't
really been studied to any great extent
i guess because
i don't know i feel like there was a lot
of it there was there was a
interest in it a lot like back around
the enlightenment era when everyone was
like really getting into like the whole
nature versus nurture thing and
also you know kind of all these um
you know intellectuals and uh you know
royalty and
stuff like that we're kind of interested
in noble savage type of stuff so it's
like they were really into
they almost kind of like collected some
of these kids
like kept them as pets sort of
because that was just something you did
they didn't really i don't think they
meant anything i don't think they meant
any harm but they just didn't
see them as people i guess
which you know that's that's causing
harm but i don't think they meant
anything
by it they just didn't they were just
like ignorant
and another thing i wanted to get into
too is that you know we can like [ __ ]
around for a little bit before we get
too much into it i just have kind of
like a
kind of like a just an overview and then
i have like a bunch of different cases
i'm going to talk about
and if we don't get to all of them you
know you know if i feel like it's going
on too long i might skip a few
but um you know so i have like several
different ones but another thing i want
to get into too is that
um i think there's kind of an
interesting thing with some of the cases
that i picked
and in the literature there's at least 4
000 cases
of these now some of them they're not
entirely sure how
uh how accurate they are because some of
them
were from a long time ago so they don't
know if it was just maybe a legend the
guy repeated or whatever
um or it got embellished over the years
but there have been some like in the
literature and whatnot
and i think what ends up happening too
is that sometimes they don't know like
by the time they find the kid for
example
um and they're kind of like massive
we're like hey they can't walk they
can't talk they can't do
or they act like an animal or you know
whatever the situation is
but you don't know if that kid
had something uh had some kind of mental
issues
prior to being left in the forest like
maybe that was the reason
that their family abandoned them because
they thought there was something that
mattered with them
and then hence they ended up like being
or if they were just normal and their
other circumstances intervened you know
poverty or whatever because there have
been some cases of that too like
especially
you know there have been kids was like
you know houses burned down or they or
they were normal but their parents were
like
you know alcoholics and like abandon
them and you know they
ran away from home and stuff and then
ended up living with animals and
things like that so it's kind of like
really hard to tease apart
how many of these kids had issues prior
to
you know becoming feral children and how
many of the
how much of the damage was caused by
their time as feral children
you know what i'm you know i'm getting
it yeah yeah there might have been
pre-existing conditions
yeah and in some cases i'm sure there
definitely was but then in some cases
there probably
wasn't yeah if you got a low-income
home where the parents are bad maybe
it's just a single mother and she's an
alcoholic
and if the kid's handicapped she doesn't
want to take care of the kid she just
kind of abandons the kid
and then it becomes a child and yeah she
abandoned the kid because the kid was
handicapped
yeah and i think that happened a lot
particularly back in the old days before
there were really any um
you know there wasn't really a lot of
understanding of mental illness there
wasn't like a lot of resources
especially if you were really poor if
you lived somewhere out in the [ __ ]
boonies somewhere
and uh you know yeah i mean i think you
i don't know if
that if you have this case in here but
there was one case that
i think was out in california where uh
they found you know this old lady i
think she was dying or something and
they went into her house and
she had a daughter who was damn tied to
a toilet
well no it's not um yeah that's that's
jeannie wiley and we're and we're going
to be talking about her
it wasn't an old lady it wasn't it
wasn't that it was nothing like that
uh yeah that's kind of one of the most
famous cases
i don't know how how long that kid had
been on of a child that had been
raised in isolation she's still alive as
far as i know
um but she kind of went off the radar in
2008 she's in an institution now and
she's apparently being taken care of
because now she's an adult but um
they're kind of trying to like keep her
privacy because
a lot of like after she was discovered
and like i said i'll get into her case
later but
um after she was discovered she kind of
got
i don't know if i want to say she was
victimized again
but people were so fascinated by her
case and they wanted to study
her because like i said here was a case
you know
of a child that had been in isolation
for you know however many year like 13
years or however long it was
and um so they kind of wanted to study
her and
uh you know and i kind of feel like not
all of the research team but one or two
of them might have gone like a little
bit too far where it was like just like
not
ethical anymore was that one of the ones
where they there may have been
pre-assisted existing conditions
well see that's i was watching a
documentary about her earlier and really
i mean
obviously at this point it's hard to say
but she had a couple of like
physical issues but nothing um nothing
that would have prevented her growing up
like a normal person as far as anyone
knows
um hers was almost entirely uh abuse
right okay so um yeah i think she had
like a couple of
genetic things but like i said it was
physical stuff it wasn't anything that
would have
you know made her like intellectually
impaired or anything like that yeah
we just thought she was or they made her
that way well hmm
yeah it was her dad pretty much entirely
was a
crazy person i mean he had also been
raised
in a very abusive household too uh which
doesn't excuse it but you know it does
kind of like give some insight into it
because
yeah that household was just i can't
even like imagine
growing up in that environment but yeah
as you're saying i read about her too i
feel bad for i know it's a horrible
horrible story
and i mean and it wasn't just her it was
like
her mom and her brother and she actually
had a couple other siblings
that died uh for various reasons
usually like neglect and things like
that and like i said it was all because
her dad was a [ __ ] lunatic
so you know we'll get into it yeah it's
it's not a happy story
but yeah so uh let's see do we have
anything that we need to i mean
we said we talked about the cookbook
already so it's like
you know everybody knows about that i
went in there and it's like i
i think because it was listed as like
adults only or explicit content or
whatever
so that might be why shit's not what the
hell is that noise
oh [ __ ] oh okay damn that was like
really close like holy crap i don't
usually hear him that loud
but um i thought it was gonna like crash
in the backyard
um but i checked it and that might be
why it's not coming up so i don't know
like how long it's gonna but i fixed it
so i don't know how long it's gonna take
to like
reset or whatever also i think i don't
know if he's here but uh
victor garcia he asked about um
because we sent him a tyrell shirt and i
think he also wanted a ouija shirt
so we need to do that at some point so
victor if you're here somewhere if
you're listening
we will do a ouija shirt for you and get
that out like early next week
so i think that's pretty much all the
like shout outs that we had right
yeah trying to get myself centered in
the shop
okay you want me to move up yeah yeah
you're always hugging i'm not hogging
yeah okay not hogging just the chair
rolls and it's just kind of like you
know
i don't know what to do about it i don't
know what to do about it
you putting your thing on yeah yeah
sandra said i read about that girl yes
she's still uh so as far as i know she's
still alive like i said the last
um that anyone really heard of her as
far as i'm aware was 2008
uh and at that point she was at a um at
a care facility in two
in uh los angeles um but they're not
like really putting it around where
she's at because
they kind of want everybody to leave her
and leave her alone you know what i mean
because uh she's had a hard enough time
so you know
it's it's just a really really sad story
but like i said she she's one of the
ones
most of the ones that i wanted to talk
about were ones that
kids that uh they were found in the
forest
some of them had been raised by animals
or at least like hung out with animals
for a time um
but she was one that you know was one
that was just isolated she lived in a
house
but um she didn't have any human
interaction pretty much her whole entire
life
and they wanted to uh study her to see
like i said uh you know
it sucks but i mean
the thing about it is that the ethics of
this are really really
it's a gray area right because obviously
you don't want to see a kid suffer
in this way but
when a case like this does arise
i can understand like wanting to
study this the person because i mean
that might help other people as well
but you really have to be careful
because like i said particularly in
jeannie's case i think there was one
woman that just kind of
i don't know it was just like she sort
of overstepped the ethics a little bit
and i think um jeannie's mom got really
pissed later on it was like trying to
sue
and all this other kind of stuff because
they said oh shoot they just
poked and prodded her and all this other
kind of stuff but like i said i can
understand like wanting to
you know wanting to study it because
it's it's a
you know it's important information to
have and like i said it could help other
people also
so what's up with those books is that
something you had to plug no
okay that's just one i was reading and
that just happened to that ashtray over
there where it is
because i see those cigarettes you see
those okay let's see those cigarettes we
gotta get this [ __ ] set up well do you
have a lighter
um did you think that far ahead
no i just saw him and you know i'm
living in here now you know
okay there all right i can always go
okay but i can't you can't put it there
though because we're here
i have to see how she does okay well he
always puts things like right in the way
like where my hand needs to go
we don't have a lighter here i don't
want okay
hey there andrea hi all just checking in
on my way to the showers trying to mow
the three foot high grass but i kicked
my butt yeah so gonna let this undo it
yeah see that's like the best way to go
about that i think
i'm i'm glad that we actually like just
have
have so have a service come do that
because i'm just like we did it for a
while and i'm just like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
it's florida
it's florida i don't go outside unless i
absolutely have to
that's not true i go for a walk every
morning but uh
yeah so obviously like i said we're
talking about
feral children i can't believe that
we're only 24 minutes
in and tom isn't like [ __ ] around
[Laughter]
veronica says hey jenny hey um
i don't know if you're just saying hey
or if you're like gonna ask me something
but i guess we'll find out in a second
um so yeah so there's what the
[ __ ] up mazenga man it's not a
complete museum but
well do you want to show that before we
get too much into this or no
are you just putting no no it's just in
the background oh okay i didn't realize
i thought
it's just in the background i will say
one thing though
what's that i'm gonna tell sandra that
we ate peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches before the show we did yeah
running out of time and made two peanut
butter jelly sandwiches
with butter on them and everything yeah
toasted
sandra says how's path kitty he's doing
good i didn't see him today like i
didn't see him this morning but i saw
him
yesterday and the day before like i
brought him some food and he ate it all
it's funny because i saw him yesterday
and i almost didn't see him because i
was walking down the path and he hangs
out by
there's like you know the fence where
the back of his house is it's like a
farm
and then there's a bench that's like
right on the side of the path
and then there's kind of trees and [ __ ]
like that and he was like all
loafed out like right next to this kind
of pile of wet leaves because it had
been storming and he looked like a
little rock
and i almost didn't see him so i just
like almost went trekking on by and then
his little head turned around
and i saw his big old eyes and he was
like and i was like well hey bud i
didn't see you
he was camouflaged but yeah he seems
like he's doing real good i didn't see
him today but like i said i've seen him
in the past couple days and he seems
like he's doing good
somebody somebody left ostensibly some
food for him
but i was i was looking at it because i
brought him a bag and i was like oh hey
bud it looks like somebody left you some
food but i
could not tell you what the [ __ ] that
was it looked
like do you know what it looked like it
looked like a pile of
lucky charms but without the
marshmallows
but with whipped cream on it i'm sure
that's not what it was
but that's kind of what it looked like
from far away okay
and uh mr mcguire did not want to eat it
because he went over there and he kind
of smelled it and he's like
no no thanks
[Laughter]
he did eat all the stuff i gave him
though i gave him that little
fancy piece like in that bag back there
which is i'm that's good and kind of low
i might have to like order some more
soon
veronica says how's your halloween game
coming i just have to do
i have to finish the board which is
almost done and then i have to do the
box and then it'll be done
but like i said i was trying to get it
done this past week but then
the other [ __ ] intervened but there's
not really that much left to do
and then i'd have then i have to upload
it and then i have to order a copy
and then i could put it up for sale so
i'm gonna try and get it before i was
gonna try and do it before last
halloween but of course that didn't work
out
so i'm gonna try it before this
halloween you know what i mean
so what nothing no okay i didn't know if
you had anything to add
yeah it says andrea says tom must not be
drinking enough yeah right
no i'm drinking well drink faster i'm
trying to get it down
it's gonna be good i'm just waiting to
see how the show's gonna go get it down
your neck hole
yeah and get it down your neck smoking
these herbal cigarettes
yeah so uh
you were kind of a feral child tom
we all were back
[Laughter]
we were all like that yeah just running
around
yeah no it's a big difference between uh
us and these kids right i mean we could
talk
well yeah the main thing about feral
children is that the
they can't speak or they just bark like
dogs act like dogs [ __ ] jump around
like dogs
had a damn little pretty russian girl
[ __ ] run around like a damn dog
yeah we're gonna talk about her [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was weird [ __ ] we're gonna
talk about her
yeah even her body was kind of narrow
and shaped like a dog i think from
running on all fours all the time
although it's weird because a lot of
these kids um
they lived within like during kind of a
you know a formative
time yeah but sometimes it wasn't for a
really long time
sometimes it was just for well you know
sometimes just for like a few years
yeah from kid's point of view a few
years is a long time that's what i'm
saying but it was like the formative
years you know what i mean
yeah so that's the thing they don't
sometimes they learn to talk
um but as i said they they usually have
some kind of impairment in that regard
they don't like learn a lot of
grammatical structure and stuff
yeah um you know depending on when they
you know were feral uh a lot of them
cannot be convinced to wear clothing
um you know a lot of them don't want to
like sleep in beds a lot of them don't
really have any interest in
humans like what humans are doing uh
they don't really
learn to bond with anybody uh you know
they they can't
obviously they eat with their hands they
can't use the toilet they can't
do all that kind of stuff um some of
them some stuff can be taught but it
depends
like i said on the on the kid and it
depends on
what age they were uh you know and
how and if people take care of them
later on
because i do kind of want to talk about
there was kind of one famous case that
was from
the uh the 18th century i want to say
that was kind of well known and he
actually had a doctor
that worked with him for like a really
really really long time
and even then when he had somebody
working with him every single day
he never really did learn to talk you
know what i mean
like he learned a couple words he could
understand kinda when you were talking
to him
but he never they never could teach him
how to talk which is
it's really kind of sad but uh yeah so
and i so i talked a little bit about
this earlier too about the
what they call the critical period
hypothesis where it's basically saying
if you don't learn
a language like a human language within
a certain window
then you can never master it they're not
saying that you can't learn
words or you can't learn you know how to
communicate
they're just saying that you're never
going to learn like a language and then
an interesting thing too is that i guess
there's a lot of debate about
what the window is for um
learning a second language because you
know how the older you get
you know the harder it is to learn a
second language
um they think that if you learn a second
language between when you're about two
or
thirteen um is usually the best time but
obviously people have learned second
languages
you know when they're older it's just
more difficult i think portuguese about
14 15. yeah it only took six months yeah
yeah with a tutor and the yeah and the
thing about it too is that
you already have the framework because
you already learned english
you know what i mean it's not like you
were just you know trying to learn a
language at 15 out of nowhere you
already had
the grammatical structure you know to
learn a language so
learning another one isn't is harder but
it's not
you know impossible i'll tell you
brazilian girls were a big motivation
for me to learn in portuguese
well there you go i had to know what was
going on yeah yeah well and yeah and
like i said the
motivation is another thing too if you
don't really want to learn it or if you
don't give a [ __ ] about
it it's going to be a lot harder also
you know but yeah it's all about
neuroplasticity
uh you know at what stage does
you know because you can learn things
forever but there are certain things
that i guess that there's a window and
if you don't get that window then
you know then there's little chance that
you're gonna get it later on
there are exceptions to that because
there were a few
supposedly feral children usually girls
for some reason um that actually did
learn to
speak later on um but
it's not not all that common now
interestingly there's one case that kind
of gets brought up a lot
and this is from uh this was this was
written out in 1926
and this happened in i guess it was
india
and um it was amala and kamala they were
supposedly like the wolf girls they used
to be called it's a very famous case
um and i was going to talk about that
one but then like the more i read about
it
the more it seems like that one was
maybe a fraud
as in these two little girls were real
um and they were at an orphanage but
they
don't think that these were ever feral
children they thought that they just had
mental issues and that the guy that was
running the orphanage where they were
was just trying to get money for the
orphanage and it was kind of a big deal
to say oh they were fair
they were raised by bears or whatever
raised by wolves
and uh so to get like press and to get
sympathy and like to get money and stuff
so they don't think that these little
girls were actually raised by wolves
so there was that uh whole case as well
but that's like kind of a real famous
one
now before i guess the 1600s like i said
it seemed like a lot of the feral
children i'm not saying that it didn't
happen
i'm sure it happened a lot more back
then they just didn't really know that
much about it
um because it seems like there were a
lot of legends about that kind of [ __ ]
you know what i mean you had like
romulus and remus and all that kind of
it's like people that were raised by
wolves or bears or whatever and they
don't really know how much of that was
true i mean it obviously it must have
happened
there was uh a story i remember
reading when i back when i was in high
school over in brazil
we had a reference book that had a bun
it was a book on demonology
and it had a bunch of excerpts from
other books and it was a story about
i think it some guy i think it was
somewhere in germany or france i don't
know it might have been germany or
austria
where he was like uh said he was a
werewolf he's going around and he was uh
raping and eating women girls oh yeah i
wanted to do a show on that dude
actually yeah
and when they caught him
he kind of spoke freely about what he
was doing and it turned out that
he lived with his sister and their
children
and some weird [ __ ] out in the cottage
out in the middle of the woods
and that they had been living out there
together since they were like little
kids like eight or nine
that their parents had died yeah that's
some blue lagoon right yeah
so they were kind of like feral kids
well yeah i guess they would be
he thought he was turning into a wolf
and he would turn into he he thought he
turned into a wolf
and he would run down uh girls that he
liked and uh
kill him rape him and then eat them and
i think in that order
eat pieces of them yikes and then uh
they went the whole thing where you know
he
he had himself exercised and they kind
of forgave him of his sins and then they
put him on the wheel and tortured him to
death
and then his sister and all them little
kids
that was the best that's how they rolled
up how they rolled in the medieval
period the good old days
jesus christ they're like yeah we saved
your soul but now you gotta pay for that
they had him on the wheel and they were
poking his [ __ ] skin out with red hot
pinchers and
[ __ ] plucked his eyes out and [ __ ]
roasted parts of him and they were doing
all this [ __ ] to him they did the same
thing to his sister
and and the children because they were
all born of sin
i'm like i'm fascinated by uh
the medieval period and i'm fascinated
by all of the torture [ __ ] that they
came up with like i said i even went to
the medieval torture museum in saint
augustine which is actually really cool
yeah but in a way it's like it's really
cool but then it's kind of like
it really makes me sad because i'm just
like look at all of the thought
they put into making these to
inflict as much agony as possible
that just makes me very very sad yeah
that's how the medieval period was
yeah everything was just a was a vicious
cartoon
yeah they weren't they i don't think
they were fully sentient
really at that point i don't think
there's just something about the way
they developed they were [ __ ] all
psychopaths i think only a psychopath
could really
survive that period i mean one of the
things that they would do is they would
take a person and they would
clamp their feet down to the ground
solid they were kind of spread eagle
they couldn't read lift their feet and
they made them hold on to some [ __ ] they
had something they had to have their
hands held in a certain position
and two guys would get on either side of
them grab a [ __ ] tree saw and saw
that dude from the crotch up alive
that was another one that they would do
it's like why would you think that you
think about that
like why would you even think of that
because like like i
well yeah but it's like and you know i
can't really say because
look i've got drawings of them dude i
know like i'm a horror writer okay
so i can think of things like that but i
would never do it to a real person
that's horrifying
you weren't a medieval well i know that
[ __ ] were psychos
i guess they must have been yeah like
let's sit around and think about like
the worst part i mean
yeah i and i'm a pretty imaginative
right and like i said i've seen
i'm a horror writer i've watched all the
horror movies and stuff like that but
some of the stuff that they had in that
museum and they like explained how it
worked and stuff like who the [ __ ]
thinks of this
who thinks of this well you know psychos
like yeah there
there are books about manners from that
period
that make recommendations that are just
[ __ ] crazy like
why would you even recommend that like
somebody must have been doing this
for them to tell you not walking down
the street do not pick up the dead rats
and smell them and definitely don't let
other don't make other people smell them
so kind of [ __ ] is that you're walking
down the street look at the dead rat
man oh it stinks here smell that i mean
[ __ ]
when you're sitting at the table when
you're sitting at the dinner table don't
take a duh they say [ __ ] like that
god damn it yeah okay
so you're impinging on my freedoms
though yeah
i don't think that's what it was no i'm
just joking i think i think
uh in certain in certain types and
evidently the royals were not that much
better than that no i don't think that
either it was just that there was
something about them
that they were just lacked lacked
development it was just the world
and they were coming from kind of like a
a city type environment it was real
filthy you know in certain areas
maybe some more of that lead poisoning
and no it's
all actually all kind of different
poisoning who knows what the [ __ ] kind
of bacteria was floating around back
then they're all like wallowing and
[ __ ] yeah the plague was coming and
wiping them out i just think only a
psychopath survived it
and um it was real harsh and there was
just no education and
no i mean even art suffered you know
what i mean they lost the ability to
draw a picture
nothing had any perspective to it uh
they couldn't
really um they couldn't really carve
anything or make statues
especially if you compared it to like an
ancient roman statue or a greek statue
[ __ ]
hell no it was i think
culture ran backwards for about 500
years although what was weird is that
some of their technology was going
forwards
yeah wasn't all of it well like i said
not everything moves forward at the same
pace and sometimes [ __ ] goes backwards
you know
yeah so it's not everything's not like
clean and neat
social social refinement was running
backwards and education was running
backwards
weapons technology was going forwards it
was weird
which is like i said that's depressing
weapons technology and architecture and
building things out
let's let's not teach everybody to read
let's just like make the worst [ __ ]
it was the priorities yeah that's what i
mean that was their priority
the priority was defense because they
were all attacking each other they were
real warlike so you so
weapons and defense that was the main
priority i mean i was gonna say though
back when you were talking about like
picking up the dead rat and smelling it
and making somebody else smell it
people still do that nowadays like they
take the milk out of the fridge
and they smell the milk the milk this
smells really bad smell that and i'm
just like i don't want to [ __ ] smell
it i trust you
here taste this this tastes like [ __ ]
kind of
like an animal instinct i think they
were some people still
i'm just like [ __ ] off i don't want to
[ __ ] taste i'm just i'm talking about
this because it's all about feral
children yeah and i think in certain
ways
the medievals were a lot like animals
they were partly feral i think
well they might have been because they
didn't really well particularly
they didn't grow up in their development
wasn't the same as ours so yeah we
didn't end up with this
as an animalistic person and what
they've learned
uh from studying feral children as you
know as
not that extensive as the study of them
is
is that basically it's not only language
but
kids you know during their the formative
years of their development
really need a lot of like intellectual
stimulation there's a lot of stuff with
their health
and everything like that or it has
effects their whole entire life
so you know no pressure anybody like
raising kids or anything like that i
mean
most things are okay as long as you keep
the kid healthy and like teach them [ __ ]
and you know love them and everything
like that they'll usually turn out all
right
but i don't think they really knew that
back then because
one the you know obviously the hygiene
was appalling
um you know there was no education to
speak of
so these kids are just being born and if
they didn't die of some horrible disease
which is now easily preventable
you know they weren't going to school
they weren't like interacting with other
kids they weren't
you know at that um what was funny about
the medievals according to the church
the church was the main stabilizing and
educating force of the medieval period
and their record said that their main
priority
was to teach people not to beat or rape
women they had to be taught that don't
beat or rape women
yeah that was the whole thing about the
ver the promotion of the virgin mary
thing
is to try to get these dudes to respect
femininity
yeah it evidently took a while for them
to do that because there was that does
not surprise me at all yeah that there
was no
not a fault there was no example of
femininity
other than the virgin mary they would
just make these supermodel pretty
statues by their standards and they
would say this is the way a woman should
hear the virgin and this is the virgin
maryland you should treat your women
like the virgin machine they're like
this this is the way a woman is
and treat women like this and evidently
it stopped a lot of that
so there were a lot of the church did
help advance these people you know they
were [ __ ] savage
yeah you know i mean [ __ ] you're not
you're not talking about televangelists
this was a very different period
well it was kind of the only like i said
for a lot of the population who were
not literate yeah it was kind of like
their only education the only
the only social outlet maybe yeah
because i think you know a lot of them
like grew up on farms
one of the means to control them too and
it was their only access to art and
literature
yeah was to go in there and sing songs
and look at damn statues
and look at stained glass windows yeah
to bring them out of the damn field
yeah and you know like i said i'm not a
big fan of the church but
you're right i mean that was probably
that was the only thing they had going
on best thing they had yeah yeah and if
they didn't have that they'd just been
running around
right raping killing people yeah and i
mean you know they did that anyway but
probably they would have
it would have been worse yeah without
that
but yeah so so like i said even though
there hasn't been a lot of study about
feral children that was kind of one of
the questions that it uh that it brought
up
like i said particularly during the
enlightenment when everybody was worried
about
uh or everybody had just become
interested in the whole nature versus
nurture debate
um you know what makes a human a human
um
you know can you know and you had kind
of this thing between
uh you know sort of the romanticism that
kind of stuff like russo
and all them that were kind of saying oh
you know man in a state of nature
that's the way he should be like you
should kind of keep him away from
society so he can develop like the way
he's naturally supposed to
um and that's really not how it works
out like you actually do kind of need
society education stuff like that to be
a civilizing force otherwise
you know and feral children are example
of what happens when you don't have that
you just have these profoundly disabled
children
and like i said it's no fault of their
own it's usually because they're
abandoned or they ran to
ran away when they were very young and
they were just learning
from the environment that was around
them jeffrey art said some cool [ __ ]
though i read somewhere that many
clergymen died during the plague
so the church just quickly ordered
ordained crooks to become priests
and monks which that makes a lot of
sense because yeah that wouldn't
surprise me
so many people died during those plagues
i imagine you just anybody who was
around got hired
so you'd have a lot of bad people
somebody else mentioned the inquisition
yeah the inquisition
the thing is is that takamata in the
acquisition didn't happen during the
dark ages that was
that was actually uh 1500's wasn't it if
it maybe even the 1600s
i mean that [ __ ] went on went for a long
time yeah thank you zach
and that was nowhere near as bad as some
of the stuff that was happened in the
middle ages
the position you could get out of it all
you had to do was convert
but you know they were trying to force
jews to convert you know i mean jews
weren't going to give up their faith
they're like [ __ ] that so they were you
know
they ended up [ __ ] torturing a lot of
them now i don't know how many of them
were killed
and i think it was all piecemeal just
depending on where it was and who was in
charge
nothing was [ __ ] you nothing was
uniformed in those
in those and i'm sure they didn't keep
super accurate records either
it's not like they had a spreadsheet or
something even in the south in the 1800s
man [ __ ]
southerners didn't keep records not not
at all that's what i mean
the longer ago it is it's like the less
there's just no way of knowing
i mean like i said when we talked about
this before like history you really need
to have like several different sources
that didn't know each other
kind of coming together on one thing
being like okay well that must have
happened because all these disparate
people like talked about it
yeah you know in that particular way
most of the south was so rural
yeah you might have some records in a
courthouse but every 50 or 60 years they
burned those records to make rooms for
new ones
just none of that [ __ ] was kept yeah
it's like they didn't have you
shouldn't store stuff in the cloud
everything had to be on like parchment
most of what we know about the history
of the south
in when it comes to detail is family
letters that have been passed down
and then what was written in the letter
you're only going to be able to get
things like certain dates and where they
were on a certain date a lot of the
other [ __ ] was just an opinion
yeah the person that's writing and
they're writing and they don't really
know the full story either
well yeah because they're only one
person it's only one person right but
yeah thank you zach
uh semi-related but have you thought of
doing a show on autism specifically
as it's literally unexplained that i
think it's fascinating on top of having
it
i have actually thought about doing that
because it is a yeah fascinating topic
um so yeah we probably will get around
to it one of these days
and um i think there might have been
some autism involved in a couple of
these cases as well but obviously they
didn't know what that was back then
so you know now rusty blossom maybe
historians would know
no historians get their knowledge from
things like letters and evidence and the
evidence in the letters aren't there
for a lot of [ __ ] most things are just
known in general
yeah they i mean they can piece certain
things together like i said if you have
a bunch of
like i said if you have a bunch of
different individuals who don't know
each other and they're all writing about
a particular event
right um then you can be pretty sure
yeah that event happened pretty much the
way it said because so many different
people who didn't know each other talked
about it
um but you know other than that you
basically cannot trust history
even roman history because we have two
major roman history books
they never agree they both disagree with
each other and they're written at
different times
uh the only thing they agree on is names
and dates but the opinions about what
happened on those
dates those names depended on who was
writing the history book
because you hired a man to write a
history book and he sure
certainly wasn't going to talk bad about
the family of the dude who's hiring him
to write
the damn right and he's not gonna and
the romans had
political parties the reds and the
whites the demagogues and the
optimates kind of like the republicans
and the democrats
depending on what political party they
were in they were gonna make their guys
look like the good guys in the
opposition party look like the bad guys
so no roman histories really
really uh really back each other up just
the dates and the names and the places
but the reasons given and the tone of it
is very different
because it's spin i was gonna say it's
just uh it's just like if you were an
artist you had to
uh you know you'd have your patron that
was paying you the money yeah and it's
like so you had to make them look as
good possible right
even if they were ugly as [ __ ] which a
lot more and roman historians only noble
families and people who are related to
the emperors that's all that's who
that's what history survived and you
weren't going to write bad about you
we're going to write bad about the
[ __ ]
family of the emperor you work for no
way
so you know i mean it's interesting
because i'm i'm interested in the
history of
you know royal families and all that
kind of [ __ ] but i'm also kind of
interested in
um histories about just like regular
people which is much harder
to come by like i said they have to kind
of piece that together
i have this one really great book i
think it's part of a series but i only
have one of them
um and it's about ancient rome but it's
about like how regular people lived
like what their houses looked like like
with their jobs and it was like really
really interesting it's like a huge huge
book it's like a textbook but like i
said it's a whole
it's a whole series but i only have like
the ancient realm one most of the
southern stuff is just writing home to
your mom or your wife
or your to your husband talking about
where you're going and what train you
got and what it was like at the station
and what something or other said what
certain relatives said what they did
that's just but sometimes that's kind of
more interesting because
you know nobody historians are writing
for posterity
yeah and people and people that are just
writing letters
are not so a lot of times there's kind
of details in there that maybe a
historian
wouldn't think to write down right um
but that so that's why i like that
little kind of [ __ ] i have this other
book
too that's all about um you know
i think it was like pre-civil war but it
was all like women in the south
and it was all like letters that they
wrote to one another their husbands and
stuff like just like you said i found it
like in a thrift store or something like
that
i was like wow that sounds really
interesting and um it was all women's
letters and you know pamphlets and [ __ ]
that they'd written back then
and it was just like a really
interesting it was just everyday people
so it was like a really interesting look
into just everyone's like everyday lives
back then
a lot of it was what they what what they
got the market and what kind of clothes
they were making
yeah how the farm was doing how the
crops came out that year
what the tomatoes look like that kind of
[ __ ] well yeah that was the [ __ ] you
were uh
worried about yeah yeah uh happy early
birthday brad
also having lots of birthdays this
month um yeah zach says i think stuff
like that is fascinating because it
isn't the topics and subjects that have
been done to death over and over
yeah see that's why i really really i'm
really interested in histories
of stuff that most people don't think
about the history of
most of the stuff i read that was
southern was [ __ ] like all the tomatoes
are looking good this year we're gonna
make a [ __ ] ton of money
if i can get these damn worms off of
them that kind of stuff the caterpillars
are eating this up
you know that's good stuff like that so
same kind of stuff that people talk
about nowadays like they have a garden
and it's like god damn grasshoppers are
eating my tomatoes
like my grandmother used to say trying
to save up money to buy something from
mama
she said she wanted to this and that she
said she wanted a grandfather clock i
can't afford that [ __ ]
yeah because that's stuff like that the
grandfather clocks were really yeah yeah
yeah
that was some fancy rich person that's
it it was like having a pc or something
it was that's like the height of
technology
[Laughter]
old newspapers are cool too because i
really like all the ads for like the
products and stuff
uh yeah old sears catalogs i love that
kind of [ __ ] because like i said it's
something that a historian wouldn't
write down necessarily because it wasn't
like a battle or nothing
so it's just like regular people [ __ ] i
don't know that's just really
interesting to me
all right so let's kind of talk about
uh some cases of this and like i said i
just kind of picked
some sort of well-known ones i picked
them at random
if we don't get time to get to all of
them it's you know whatever i definitely
want to talk about jeanne so i have her
last but
um you know so if we don't we're not
doing too bad we're only like at an hour
okay so you know so i'll probably get a
chance to because
some of the cases aren't as complex as
some of the other ones
so let's talk about uh peter the wild
boy
now this is interesting i was just
watching a little short document wasn't
really documentary it was only like
seven minutes long
but it was like a little thing that the
bbc had done and there is actually this
guy is actually buried
at um st mary's at north church in
hertfordshire
england uh you know so there's a little
grave there that says peter the wild boy
on it and uh to this day people still
leave flowers on his grave even though
he died in 1785.
so he was found when he was they
they weren't entirely sure they thought
that maybe he was just going through
puberty it was right about in that times
they think that he was maybe 11 or 12
years old when they found him
so he was all he was naked when they
found him he was all like disheveled
looking
he was living by himself in a forest in
hanover
germany actually not too far from the
town of hamlin
of pied piper fame um yeah
so he walked on all fours uh he ate with
his hands
he couldn't talk obviously uh and really
really really didn't like wearing
clothes
so he was found by hunters or somebody
that was just going through the forest
or whatever so they
uh were like oh look at this we found a
feral child
so they brought him back to uh
king george the first of great britain
uh because his family was from hanover
and they're like hey we found this feral
boy
and king george got like really uh super
into it
so they bring the kid to london
and essentially made him like i said
it's sad it happened a lot around this
time period they essentially turned him
into a human pet
at kensington palace yeah um you know
well that makes a lot of sense though
yeah what year was this again
1780s 1780s they had no idea no way
no knowledge of even basic psychology or
psycho actually 1725 it wasn't
that was you know in the middle ages
they'd killed his ass
true that's a werewolf never [ __ ] cut
that kid's head off
that's true so no making him a pet would
be the best thing you can do for him
yeah and that's kind of the thing it's
like in a lot of ways
you know from our point of view like if
you've got a kid in the woods obviously
it's like oh let's
take him to court and like make him do
tricks and stuff no one's going to do
that nowadays
but like you said compared to what they
would have done earlier
or what would have happened to him had
he continued to live in the woods that
was probably
not the worst fate that could have
before yeah and this is a king and his
men so you're talking about the elites
of the time
and the [ __ ] educated best best
educations of the time
and i'm sure they were just like well
this is obviously a normal phenomenon
this is not paranormal this isn't
possession or
it's this is not a werewolf this is a
kid that was raised out in the wild
so then we'll try to teach him how to
talk and be good to him when that fails
a couple days later because they
probably wouldn't know how long to wait
yeah in a few weeks i guess he's not
gonna learn how to talk well we'll just
take care of him he thinks he's a dog
we'll just treat him like a dog it'll be
fun
you know that's yeah that would have
been let's just make him roll
that would have been the most humane
thing you could do
in that time period in those
circumstances yeah guess yeah just let
him be
don't mess with him you can't fix it you
know the lord will take care of him
that's what they would think about you
know and we'll just enjoy this spectacle
you know that's yeah so it's win-win
win-win
everybody's having a good time because
look even the experts of today can't fix
this
so it's kind of the right call just let
him be
and the thing about it is that modern
ones that they've found
a lot of times depending on how long
they lived in the forest or if they live
with animals or something like that
a lot of them when they live with human
size they're very unhappy
yeah and they want to go back to the
woods yeah so no i'm going to give it to
king george he made the right call for
his time period
especially and i mean like i said that
was very common too among royal families
it's like you know when they
any time they discovered some new race
of people like someone when they were
exploring ooh
kidnap one of those and bring it back to
the courts everybody can go up at it
you know what i mean that made sense too
for the time too yeah i know
i know they did that to a lot of native
americans they did yeah they'd capture
one
and they'd bring it they brought one guy
to squanto i think they did it to squat
they did he ended up being famous later
on yeah uh he helped out with john smith
took him back to england and showed him
off and he met all the kings and all the
royalty and everything and
if i can spend a lot of time in the bars
he he was a slave technically but they
didn't
they didn't lock him up they treated him
like a
prostitute a zoo exhibit and a and a
celebrity and then they kind of lost
interest in him
over yeah well that kind of happened and
he just let him free they let him free
and he said [ __ ] it he went back
to america he jumped on a ship and went
back to america yeah he's like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and when he got back he found out
his all
his whole tribe had been wiped out by a
pandemic yeah while he was gone
yeah and that's the pandemic was brought
by the spaniards yeah
thanks spain well it would have anybody
could have brought any european i know
i'm just kidding
but that's a well yeah
it's just it's funny that i mean like i
said it's funny to us now because it's
kind of like they didn't understand that
like everyone's like humans are just
humans
and so it's almost kind of like it's
like ooh look it's like a it's like a
person
you know what i mean i'm like yeah it is
a person
but they knew it was a person they just
were amazed
yeah you know because it's like that oh
and everything like that
they weren't used to anything that was
different yeah just like wow look at
that
that's true check that [ __ ] out yeah
what are you wearing
right yeah it was like that kind of
thing yeah so
yeah so that's kind of what happened to
this kid although at least this kid
probably wasn't
like uh cognizant enough to be pissed
off about it
um you know what i mean so yeah so they
brought him in now they weren't entirely
sure
if peter the wild boy was raised by
animals there was some speculation that
he had been raised by bears or perhaps
wolves
uh but they weren't entirely sure
because like i said they just found him
by himself um
in area where bears and wolves were
um so as i said this was kind of a big
thing
like this was right around the time
period when you were getting like uh
everyone getting super into like natural
history and
into uh origin of man and uh you know he
had carl linnaeus and he was doing like
the taxonomy and everything like that
so everyone was kind of like word like
they were becoming interested in like
classifying humans into like different
species groups
and all that kind of stuff so so
this was like a big huge sensation right
and um he kind of caused a lot of
debates also
again about does he have a soul he can't
talk and it's like you know what
is he a human what makes us human that
kind of stuff and he kind of like
brought up a lot of questions like that
um it's interesting too because carl
linnaeus who i guess was it was a
contemporary
and he um made a new category of human
in his very famous uh book system uh
nature
natori uh just for him which was called
juventus hanoveranus or hanover anus
if you if you prefer
i thought it was a different species
yeah okay
or like yeah that was kind of the thing
that there because they were kind of
like they weren't sure
they didn't see a lot of this and like i
said there was still a lot of
religion lingering over the [ __ ] so they
were just kind of like well if the
person can't talk or doesn't act like a
person
like you know or like people that they
were familiar with
then they were like just do they have a
soul or are they just like an animal
yeah you know what i mean so they kind
of like thought of it as a difference
because of them as a different species
it was the science of the day yeah yeah
yeah they didn't really uh
understand i understand what was going
on so well i don't think the scientific
method was fully adopted
but they were trying to categorize
things yeah and
which was the start it's a type of
genius when you think about it
because before this period i'm not
talking about the roman period but in
the medieval period
yeah people didn't question anything
things things were what you saw
and if you didn't like it it was bad
kill it yeah that was the thinking i
mean they were
and uh the spirits and superstition
and uh and emotion that was everything
was emotion
yeah to this point so they didn't even
make a really a strong
effort to categorize anything the
medievals actually believed in things
called dog heads
they believed that there was a type of
people out there that had the heads of
dogs
yeah i read some articles and they
actually believed that they existed that
they were always existed somewhere else
they were always looking for them and
the church had decided that yes they
were people and that they had souls
and that they needed and that some of
them were christians and the ones that
weren't christians needed to become
christians oh so they're all christians
so they're talking about theology with
mythological beings that they had no
proof of
which is hilarious they just believed
where they yeah so but i mean they
didn't think it was hilarious they took
it very seriously yeah
but it's funny it's funny to me right
we're just going to show you what's
possible with the human mind
yeah we come up with all kind of crazy
yeah if you don't have a framework
you'll believe in some wild ass [ __ ]
true well like i said that's why i think
that's why i'm a big like enlightenment
advocate i'm just like
the whole scientific method is probably
the best
thing that we have ever come up with
yeah if it's a problem-solving tool and
to understand
as a process right to try to understand
the uh the world you know yeah
and some people say well the sciences
you know are pure
the creators of these science is like
[ __ ] um
oh what's his name guy who invented
physics
uh newton newton was the [ __ ] genius
by any
measure he was a genius and he figured
out physics and calculus
just by sitting around and thinking
about it and doing little experiments
but that same guy believed in alchemy
yep
and believed people are complicated yeah
yeah he did
right now he was kind of right
alchemy is a [ __ ] pseudoscience but
it's a prototype of of of chemistry
and i think yeah he wasn't that he
wasn't that far off
he he knew that physics was real and
there's something with chemistry that
that molecules things are made out of
molecules
and the things like one thing could turn
into another thing which is true
right that can happen but when you
looked at when you looked at
when you looked at alchemy for what it
was it was a spiritual process
of eventually trying to find something
pure the pure
sorcerer's stone or a pure element
they don't know the [ __ ] they're talking
about no the closest thing to what
they're talking about maybe maybe like
nuclear plasma
that's pretty damn pure something had
going on in a fission or fusion
like fusion would be fusion plasma
maybe but they had no concept of that
no they just thought it was something
because the sorcerer's stone was
something that you could kind of like
i guess ingest or become it and
and be without sin and live forever
maybe
there was some spiritual process
involved with this it had to do with
your soul
which that's nothing scientific with
that well no and it's just like it's
really
interesting though and that's another
thing that i always found interesting
like the early scientists like you said
a lot of them did believe in a lot of
crazy [ __ ] yeah
but that's because they didn't i mean
the scientific method hadn't really been
codified yet
to a point where they still held a lot
of supernatural
beliefs and but they were trying to
apply the same framework to that so
there was still like a lot of overlap
which
is like really interesting the problem
was is that they believed in science but
science could not contradict their
beliefs in the bible
and their beliefs in god because they
saw science as a way of explaining god's
creation
yeah so therefore science was a
religious mechanism to validate the
bible
all right well i hate to say but there's
still a small minority of dudes nowadays
that still
uh that are still trying to do that if
science starts coming into
starts questioning the scripture then
that's not science
so you back off of it yeah so that's
what that's what the problem was
i mean there were no it wasn't they
weren't all like that
yeah it's just that the ones that were
writing were like that
because you couldn't write otherwise you
could get in [ __ ] serious trouble
well yeah i have a feeling that a lot of
guys maybe who weren't even as smart as
newton
thought that uh this this bible thing's
probably a lot of [ __ ]
well [ __ ] people have been saying that
since the beginning of right right um
like and not even like even before the
bible was written they were saying it
about
other beliefs is like prior belief
systems um
like i said if you haven't read who the
[ __ ] wrote this book i think it's called
uh freethinkers it's by susan jacoby and
she
does like a history like going back
thousands and thousands of years of
essentially atheists and how far back
that thought goes
like people questioning yeah it's like
since the beginning of human
civilization or writing like people have
been well plato said that plato yeah
said it nah these are superstitions yeah
you know the only reason why we believe
these is because our parents told us to
believe in them and it's been going on
for generations
yes there's no gods on mount olympus so
he eventually [ __ ]
ordered him to commit suicide for saying
that because you couldn't say that even
in the greek age
they said that well you're corrupting
the youth so you gotta go
you gotta go you gotta go he was an old
man though he was like [ __ ] you i'll
drink it
that was socrates yeah excuse me
socrates
yeah yeah i remember that yeah i think
she's talking
yeah it was played on socrates evidently
supposedly talked to each other
yeah in these writings it was socrates
that one yeah yeah but that yeah she
talks about him in there too but
yes he was probably the first codified
atheist
yeah i mean yeah from his writings he
definitely does come across like that
and he i mean he just like questioned
everything he didn't believe in the kind
of
he said if there's an afterlife he goes
he says if there's an afterlife then
it's probably awesome there's there's no
reason
to fear death and he goes if if he goes
i don't believe in the hell because i
can't
he said why would a god create you and
then throw you in hell he goes that's
[ __ ] and he goes
most likely you die and nothing happens
you just you just vanish into the void
yeah
and he goes if that's the case then
there's nothing to be afraid of so
therefore do not be afraid of death
which is totally logical it's either
going to be heaven or the void
yeah and either either one of those
things okay that's what that's what
socrates said yeah
yeah and i i totally endorse that
viewpoint that's true i had a near-death
experience and and out-of-body
experience i believe that
there's another dimension and you
your point of view your consciousness
kind of survives it
but you're not quite the same person
after you
make that you look back on on your life
as if it was a
movie you watched or a role that you had
played
it's not true you the true you is kind
of
a lot more simple like a little
spiritual squirrel
i would like to be a little spiritual
squirrel it's all fun
it's all fun and games and just running
around in the tree and like digging
around
for acorns join the cosmic consciousness
i'm a feral child and i was raised by
squirrels
yeah so i just sit around doing this all
the time
i still think of that one little
squirrel i have two funny squirrel
stories
one of which i came out of work one time
and i was getting in my car
and the squirrel was burying the acorn
in the
in the dirt like next to my car and the
squirrel looked at me like that
and went they can't do that you don't
see
you don't see what i'm doing yeah you
don't see trying to play it off yeah you
didn't see it
i buried that there because he thought i
was gonna take it like i was this big
giant squirrel and i was gonna take his
acorn so he was just like
yeah played it off no like backing away
yeah
and then one time at my old uh apartment
complex i was in the gym and there was
like a big
window like looking out over the pool
and i saw a squirrel
on the um the ledge like like around the
pool
and he had a a giant piece of pizza
in his mouth yeah and he was trying to
and it was kind of too heavy for him
because it was a big floppy piece
i don't know where he got it from but he
was just probably like score and he's
like carrying it on this and he was
trying not to fall off the thing and
he's like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and he's like
trying to [ __ ] it was like so [ __ ]
funny
jordan drove down said tom's a spiritual
godzilla
[Laughter]
yeah we are all spiritual godzilla's
peter says i've never heard about the
out-of-body experience no we did it i
did a whole show on it yeah that was a
while back a long time ago
i might do another one or you can talk
about it after we're done talking about
feral children if you're if you're still
coherent enough
to go here if you're still coherent
enough yeah
but yeah so uh all right so we were
talking about peter the wild boy so he
gets to
england and he becomes the ward of
uh princess caroline who later became
the queen
now she actually uh took a lot of
interest in him and she
got an education for him however
uh despite that he never did learn to
talk
um he could say a couple of words
but and he seemed to understand like
when people talked to him he seemed to
understand what they meant
but he didn't he couldn't like put
together any sentences or anything like
that
um he was also really into
wandering off you know what i mean
because he's just you know
he didn't really have any concept of you
have to stay in this one place because
he was just so used to just running
around wherever he wanted to
and as i said nobody they just found him
when he was 11 or 12 years old so nobody
knew
how long he had lived out in the forest
um and
if he had lived with other animals or
what the hell had gone on because they
just found him and he was by himself and
they didn't know how long he'd been out
there
um so one particular summer uh in 1751
he actually went missing as he did often
um so they had to end up but he was gone
for a little while so they had to put
like ads in all the newspapers and like
with a big reward like to bring him back
and everything
and then uh they didn't find him until
like a couple of weeks
later now when they found him
this is gonna sound terrible but um
you know it's you have to kind of think
about the time i guess
but so they found him it was a couple
weeks later and then they had
um this leather collar like made for him
that had and it was like engraved with
his name
and his and the address like you know if
found please bring it back to here
and like they put it on him and this
collar like still exists because this
little
um docu-like little documentary snippet
that i saw about him
um i don't remember if it's in the same
church where his grave is or i think it
was on the farm where he lived like for
a long time like before he died
because the farmers there looked after
him but they have it like in a little
box like the collar that he wore
that had sent like basically a foul
police return to like this place
you know i mean yeah so um
so as i mentioned earlier they think
and they're not sure because nobody knew
where he came from and nobody knew how
long he'd been out of the woods
but they thought maybe he had started
out as being
um mentally disabled and that his
parents had
abandoned him in the woods um
but of course there's no way of knowing
that for sure uh you know
it the way he was might have just been
uh you know a product of him being out
in the woods for a long time however
there actually is a painting of him um
which is still hangs in
the in the palace or whatever like where
he stayed for a while is it kensington
yeah i guess it was
i think that's where the painting is but
i've seen a picture of it
and more recently um
researchers have been like geneticists
and stuff been looking at that painting
which obviously painting is not like
an exact you know reproduction but they
thought it was like fairly accurate
enough
and they thought by looking at his
likeness in this painting
they suspect that he might have had
a genetic condition called pit hopkins
syndrome now this was something that
wasn't
was only identified in like 1978 and um
if you have this like i said it's a
genetic disorder
um and it has like severe neurological
effects
usually like a lot of learning
disabilities developmental
uh disabilities uh you can't uh learn to
talk
so sounds like it yeah so as i said but
well the the reason that they thought
that was because
in the portrait he doesn't look you know
this is gonna sound
insensitive he doesn't look [ __ ] up or
anything but just from
his the way his hair looked and the way
his um
mouth and his face looked they said that
looks very much like somebody with this
particular
they don't like i said they don't look
[ __ ] up but they usually have a mouth
that looks like a little
cupid's bow um they have kind of smells
of cuba's boat it's like a little
like a little bitty mouth like that
where it's kind of pointy right here and
it's not it's actually cute it's not
like
[ __ ] up looking um and he had kind of
big bushy like coarse hair
uh he was real short he had like kind of
droopy eyelids like real heavy
yeah droopy eyelids so you know and
just from listening to people because a
lot of people described this kid because
like i said he was kind of like
a sensation back in the day and you know
so they had a lot of people write about
him
so they said just from the way that but
they don't know
so they're assuming that the kid was
born like with this
genetic condition his parents didn't
know what to do with him and just
like left him in the woods which sadly
was pretty common back then
yeah when a kid was born and they didn't
really know
what to do about it's it was also you
know if a kid was born and they couldn't
feed the kids sometimes they threw the
kid away
yeah it's not they don't say much about
that but the kid in a bag put a rock in
a bag and throw the kid in the water
yeah it used to happen that well they
did that was birth abortion
yeah it's [ __ ] up but it's just kind
of like that's
they didn't really have the same i'm not
saying that it's like oh they didn't
love their kids because even like
animals couldn't feed them
take care of their kids but they
couldn't feed them yeah it got to a
point where it's like we can't feed her
or if it or like i said if there was
something
um drastically wrong with them yeah you
couldn't use them on a farm
yeah and you couldn't do anything with
them then yeah they would just like
leave them to die which is terrible
another thing this kid used to do too
they said was very funny was he was like
he was a pretty skilled pickpocket
interestingly
but he didn't really want like he was
interested in like people's watches and
stuff but obviously he was like
he'd grown up in the woods so he didn't
give a [ __ ] about money or anything like
that
he was looking for um food like if
somebody had brought him some nuts or
something like that
so he was just like going around picking
people's pockets pockets had food in him
yeah well i guess maybe food in there i
guess that's what he was looking for
yeah but it's just yeah so it was that
kind of thing but like i said he was
super super famous they did like a wax
statue of him uh that they put on
display in the strand back then
there was even like some kind of uh
you know your satirists of the day like
um daniel defoe and jonathan swift and
stuff
like even wrote stuff about him and the
satires
were kind of pointing out that maybe
peter the wild boy
was more sensible than anybody in the
court because he didn't have all of
these heirs and he didn't have like all
these silly
rituals and stuff like that he was just
like they weren't corrupt
yeah he wouldn't grow up so so that's
kind of like what they were
making a joke about was that maybe he
was like the only sane one in there
because he didn't have all these
affections they've turned him into a
meme
they did kind of uh you know like i said
but uh
just like we were talking about earlier
with squanto uh after a while though
all those nobles they get bored of even
even human pets yeah so they were just
kind of like that that was so five
minutes ago
so you know i mean at least though they
didn't just like throw them back out in
the woods
because that's what i would have thought
they would have done because that sounds
like some [ __ ] they would have done
but uh they probably got older and he
was as cute as he was you know as a kid
yeah like he's just a grown man going in
there like hey getting rid of his ass
yeah it's like yeah it's not fun anymore
um
he's picking everybody's pockets it's
not funny
but yeah so uh but they did actually
they didn't just kick him out
they actually paid to uh send him to
this farm
in hertfordshire which like i said is
kind of still there
because it was sort of on the
documentary it doesn't look exactly the
same
but um so he went and lived at this farm
and apparently like he still had the
collar on which
like i said that sounds a little [ __ ]
up but run around naked with the collar
off
he well they did mostly he didn't like
to wear clothes
they did try to like force him into
clothes just so people wouldn't be
alarmed
like this naked kid running around um
and he would wear clothes but grudgingly
right you know they put him like in a
little green outfit
and he would like a little suit um and
he was just kind of like
he was just kind of like that but most
of the time i think he would wear it but
he had a collar um
like i said that had the the name and
address of the farm on it
right well that way you know it's
because he had a tendency to wander off
and they didn't want him to get lost
where he came from
right so he's not some wild kid you know
he's got an owner
yeah you know and the farmers were kind
of like and they would give you a reward
if you found him and brought him back
um so it wasn't quite as terrible as it
sounded
um and so like i said when he died in
uh in the late 17th 1785 i believe it
was um
actually all the locals uh paid for his
headstone which still stands there today
and uh people still leave flowers on his
grave to this
very day which i thought was i thought
was kind of nice it kind of goes back to
the uh
the old village idiot [ __ ] concept
evidently every village had one
it was basically a mentally handicapped
person that they kind of took care of
kind of like a mascot yeah it sounds
like that's kind of what this guy was
a village idiot but there we go he'd run
around he's
kind of like the village clown i think
yeah i think that's kind of how they
looked at it kind of like a jester
or a clown but i think they also gave
them stuff to do
you know here you know type the horses
that kind of stuff
which like i said i don't have a problem
with that i mean as long as people
aren't like
spitting on them or kicking them or like
making fun of them or something no
evidently
evidently that was just something that
they did it's like everybody took care
of him and like let him like give him
jobs and stuff if there was something
wrong with the kid at birth that was
kind of obvious chances are they
wouldn't make it
they'd throw the kid away but a lot of
times
the so-called village idiot was a kid
that was wanted
yeah just that once he got once he got
older too old
to kill they find out there's a problem
there you know what i mean so
yeah there was no um
no organized uh social well welfare
system for
the mentally you know what i mean
handicapped so it just had to be done at
the local level
and there was actually a term the
village idiot well yeah i've heard that
and that's
yeah and that's what it was how old was
he when he died i think
i think he was pretty old it's weird
because i thought i saw a documentary
said he was 40 but i'm like no that's
not right because i think they found him
in 1725
and he they weren't sure how old he was
but they thought he was about 11 or 12
because he looked about puberty age
um and he died in 1785 so i'm assuming
he was 60 something 70 something
something like that but he lived on a
farm for a really long time and like you
said they gave him like little jobs to
do and peter garcia asked how old was he
in dog years
who was that victor assange yeah
okay that's pretty funny
i feel bad for laughing and yeah it was
a long time ago it was it was a long
time ago
and like i said he wouldn't be he
wouldn't be aware of you laughing anyway
no he probably wouldn't and honestly
it's like he had
under the circumstances he probably had
the best life he could have had
because like you said he might have
ended up like in a [ __ ] circus or he
might have ended up abused which was
something you did asylum yeah or he
could have been an asylum or something
like that so
i guess under the circumstances he
probably got the best life that he could
have had oh yeah
living at a farm hell yeah well and
living at court for a while
and like it's living in luxury yep um
you know
so even if he might not have liked it
because he wasn't used to
like i said i don't know how long he
lived in the woods though because it
does seem like a lot of these kids that
spent several years in the woods um some
of them didn't really like they didn't
really adjust all that well
back to human society and they didn't
really like it and i don't know how you
survive those german winners
see that's another thing and it's just
like i guess sound likely
i guess this is why
but well like i said nobody knows how
long he was out there he couldn't have
been out there long he might not have
been out there all that long
i don't think he'd have made one winner
yeah you don't have fur
yeah how are you going to survive that
winter i think that's what i mean
unless unless he get unless he like
lived with a pack of wolves or a bear or
something that sat on him in the
wintertime it's like i don't
see that's what somebody asked that
earlier it's like how how don't they die
of exposure
yeah it depends where it is obviously
but
germany has cold winters he wouldn't
have died yeah and it rains a lot
he wouldn't survive he couldn't have
been out there for too long
he must have been in the custody of a
family when he ran off they just let him
go
how much but he was out there only for a
few months
when he was found how much i bet yeah
that's what it's it's totally possible
that he hadn't been out there all that
long
because they they you know they're
speculating nowadays that he had
mental issues prior to that you have to
be able to hunt and find food
and that requires at least an animal
intelligence
and i don't think he would have had the
foresight animals are
actually on top of their game a lot of
people don't know that but they're
they're on top of their game well they
have to be or they would have died out
their instincts and they learn from
other animals they know how to make it
and they can plan for winters
they got food they got fur they know how
to make shelter
uh handicapped kid doesn't those
instincts aren't in him
they wouldn't make shelter they would
just get cold and curl up and lay on the
ground and they die
you would think i guess it would depend
on the kid
uh yeah honestly how does a kid without
clothes [ __ ] survive the winter
i'm just not buying it i lived outside
in the winter in the infantry
i ain't buying it i mean when you think
of it it's a good thing that humans are
smart enough to figure out technology
because we're pretty lame otherwise
[Laughter]
the only thing i could the only way only
thing i could see that
maybe somebody could live is that they
were to dig a hole and make a burrow and
get in there
yeah the problem is is that the ground's
cold
yeah and still suck the life out of you
you'd have to insulate the inside of it
and there's that's more tough [ __ ] you
have to do pine needles maybe
and i don't think the kid had whatever
it takes and
if you're not wearing any clothes it
would just suck the life out of you and
you can't hibernate like a bear
and a lot of people think hibernation is
just that you're sleeping the whole time
they're not they're awake
they're in and out of sleep they go
through damn
some species uh go through like
convulsions
in the middle of their [ __ ]
hibernation which kind of wakes them up
and they go back to sleep and then they
get back up there
their metabolism is slowed way down and
uh well and they pack on a lot of fat
too before they
humans weren't made for that no you
wouldn't survive
unless you ate like a [ __ ] ton of donuts
you couldn't sleep enough and you
couldn't
you couldn't didn't you wouldn't have
enough fat reserves
you don't have enough fur you're people
are like so [ __ ] bored you'd be like
in there going jesus christ how long do
i have to sleep in here
[ __ ] i can't do this granthar's hammer
says in michigan the mosquitoes in the
summer would drain their blood by
morning
same in florida probably yeah you would
actually down here
down here you could swing it but you'd
probably die of heat stroke in the
summertime
to be honest with you no i've lived in
i've lived in weather in in weather like
this out in the field
problems of mosquitoes at night
um the heat isn't the problem
no you could you could survive here
just be the mosquitoes and uh if you
didn't if you
didn't have any clothes they'd [ __ ] you
up
well yeah here it'd be like trying to
remember bugs and snakes and
trying to imagine critters how would you
survive without clothes
and to get sleep you'd have to get down
in the water
and that would keep the mosquitoes off
you accept your face and they'd be
attacking that
so nah that wouldn't work out long term
you might make it for a while but
like if you got in the water it wouldn't
be long eventually you'd run into an
alligator that'd drag you down deep and
drown you yeah so probably better to get
eaten by
mosquitoes than an alligator the only
thing i could think that maybe you could
do is uh
get underneath pine needles
yeah at night that'd keep mosquitoes off
you but they'd climb down in there to
get you
didn't they do remember that show naked
and afraid
didn't they do it naked and afraid out
in the [ __ ] wilds of
the swamps of louisiana or something i'd
have to see it again i don't know
i'm thinking they did one or that was
like similar enough to a florida climate
that i was just kind of like interested
to see it
i think it was out in louisiana as well
when it was hot and wet or maybe it was
the everglades i can't remember
when it was hot and wet there were
mosquitoes one of the things that we
would do
is uh you couldn't get in a sleeping bag
it was too hot
so we'd lay down a [ __ ] we would call
a [ __ ] pad it was a
it was a [ __ ] foam pad we'd get on
that
and we would put our gloves on and put
um
uh our [ __ ] rain clothes on rain
pants and rain jacket because
mosquitoes couldn't bite through it and
then you covered your face up
you know i had a damn mosquito
net it was like a hat with a mosquito
net you could drape that over your face
the mosquito yeah
and then we had deet and that way that
would help
they couldn't they would fight that [ __ ]
they would try to get through it anyway
you bit a little bit they couldn't bite
through that rubber rain suit
mosquitoes are out yeah now that was
before we had gore-tex i don't think
they could bite through that
either but the thing is gore-tex is real
hot
the rain the rain clothes that they gave
us were thin was thin
yeah and their little their little
proboscis couldn't couldn't penetrate it
that's how easy to do it naked would
[ __ ] kill you because they'd be
here whole swarms of them out there
trying to get in well like i said when
you
if you see uh you know one of the naked
and afraid ones where they're like
in an environment like that that's like
real swampy or real humid
and it's just kind of like by the time
they're done if they make it all the way
through
um their [ __ ] bodies are just covered
with [ __ ] bites
bug bites yeah like welts and stuff we
didn't evolve for this
no like i said we're pretty lame i mean
as if we didn't have big giant brains we
would technology
we would have died out a long time ago
yeah clothes have a lot to do with it we
don't have any fur we don't have any
claws we don't have
sharp teeth we don't have anything like
that without clothes humans would have
never
made it would have never left africa but
luckily
yeah we can make gunpowder and fire and
bread
machines and computers and all kind of
[ __ ] like that
yeah nuclear missiles i think the first
invention was clothing
well it would have it would have had to
be yeah you couldn't you wouldn't be
able to leave the african continent
without clothing
yeah you never survived the european
winter can you imagine it's like the
first people that kind of set out like
going to the north going [ __ ] this man
this is like freezing [ __ ] cold out
here
we got to make shoes now we got to make
a [ __ ] fur code god damn it what are
we even doing
stone cutting tools and clothes
would have been leather probably
grampur's hammer said i used to work
with one of the contestants on naked and
afraid named kelly
nightlinger she was a cop in michigan
she was the one who used her lady parts
to catch a mud puppy in africa oh i
don't think i i don't think i saw that
episode i would have remembered that for
sure
how oh my god what's a mud puppy
it's like a in it like a uh it's almost
kind of like a one of those sort of
amphibious
okay fish that it should unless i'm
thinking of something else
aren't they kind of like walking catfish
or something people say the same thing
yes what's a mud puppy yeah it's like
catfish look at that that's what i
thought
it's like it but they can come out of
the water like for extended periods of
time
like they can sort of breathe some just
said that she saw a naked afraid they
kept uh
they kept stuff away with the fire at
night mosquitoes the fire that wouldn't
work
not in florida that wouldn't work
they're just like [ __ ] your fire [ __ ]
no i've been saying we smell blood in
the military you can't make a fire
it's it's against the rules because you
can see it on thermal [ __ ]
miles away through thermal night sights
but civilian camping i've been civilian
camping here in the south of mississippi
and that
that fire won't do [ __ ] yeah i'm going
to keep mosquitoes away
you have to make some kind of a tent and
you have to have clothes on
a real tent tent the seals up that'll
keep mosquitoes out
i mean i'm fascinated by naked and
afraid though because it's like
and a lot of the people on there are
like hardcore they like and they've like
practiced for this and it's like you
know a lot of them have qualifications
that they know how to do [ __ ] and
everything
and even then it just looks
[ __ ] miserable the easiest way to do
it is you have to string up a hammock in
between two
trees and then run a bungee cord in
between the two trees above you
and then you throw a mosquito net over
the bungee cord and have it dripping
down you seal it up around the ground
because they'll try to get down that net
and go underneath the ground
we we couldn't do that in the army
that's the easiest way but you couldn't
have that in the army you couldn't have
when i was in you couldn't have a
hammock that was against the rules you
had to be on the ground
um because being off the ground
you is not good cover if somebody's
shooting at you while you're asleep
because you it'll buy you a couple
seconds to you know what i mean to be on
the ground
because as soon as you start shooting
back everybody drops down and i
worms eye view and you'd be surprised
how you can hide behind just a very
small lump in the ground
once everybody's down on all fours you
know
but you can't be above anything they
just didn't have those
but in a civilian situation the easiest
would be
string up a hammock in between two trees
take a bungee cord
if even if it takes two bungee cords
with the hooks together wrap that around
the base of the tree you want a line
over you and throw a mosquito net over
that
i'd [ __ ] have a poncho liner over it
too
uh and then stake it to the ground on
either side for water protection
in case it rains because it always rains
when you never expect it
well like i said especially in florida
[ __ ] rain sitting here all the time
right i don't think people
under i don't i don't know people that
have never been here like realize
because they're like oh it's sunny
florida and stuff like that i'm like
yeah
it is but in the summer it storms
every single day every single day i
would
and in most through most of the fall too
yeah
and you know it's too hot to get in a
sleeping bag here
yes during the summer i i would not
advise that
i would get into something like gore-tex
top and bottoms and then seal everything
up with gloves
it's too hot to sleep in our house and
we have air conditioning down at 72
degrees
yeah i still have to stick my feet out
the bottom of the blankets because air
conditioning goes out
in the house so that happens when a
hurricane comes you're [ __ ]
whole house smells like terrible because
it [ __ ] humidity yeah it smells like
a wet dog it smells like a wet dog in
here because all the [ __ ] carpets
start to get [ __ ] it's 100 humidity
the carpets just get [ __ ] damp and
humid and oh
it's terrible damn i went for a walk
this morning at seven in the morning and
it was
already humid i'm not even like i walk
fast-ish but it's like i walk three
miles and i come back and i'm just like
soaked
yeah at seven in the morning it's
already like horribly horrible so
these kids living out in the woods for a
period of time
places like germany and
louisiana or [ __ ] florida i'm not
really buying it with my [ __ ] field
experience
you have to be [ __ ] around well as i
said some of these older ones they might
not have been out there for them
because they don't know where they came
from they just found them so they're
just kind of like okay and they couldn't
tell you where they came from i got a
feeling they weren't out there for very
long they might not because you have to
be smart
you have to be equipped to survive
you can't just do it just with no
clothes yeah and no
no training and no experience and no no
knowledge and
no look at the look at the american
indians
they did that [ __ ] for [ __ ] thousands
of years they were [ __ ] experts at it
they were the [ __ ] they were like rambo
okay yeah but look at
what they had their technology was
better than ours they could you know
what i mean well yeah because like i
said they've been here for thousands
they've been here for thousands of years
they can make
clothes shelter and weapons and they
they could
uh start with nothing people said you
could capture an indian during a raid
and take him prisoner take everything
from him
and if he got loose that [ __ ] would be
back about a month later to get revenge
on you he'd be fully re-equipped
nobody's like man that's a macgyver [ __ ]
right yeah
they were in their element well yeah
like i said how to start from
zero and build up it's just funny it's
funny to think that like the europeans
came here and they thought that they
could
i mean obviously they did eventually but
it's just kind of like they thought
oh we can just like you know subdue the
name yeah
i'm just like [ __ ] they've been here
for thousands of years you've never been
here in this environment before
they've been here for thousands of years
they're completely and totally
comfortable with it
and you aren't they know their way
around and you don't
um you know what i mean so i hear all
this [ __ ] you know well we had guns
in this net
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you don't know the [ __ ]
indians didn't give a [ __ ] about guns
until the advent
of the [ __ ] metallic cartridge case
and that was 1800s
in the 15th and 1600s it was match locks
and flintlocks
they were worthless here if it got wet
you couldn't use it
they were just crude noise fight the
rate of fire was too slow
and what it was good for was a club
that's what that's what a gun was
a club you could use it to hunt but it
wasn't good in combat
indians would [ __ ] you up they had bows
that fired a lot better
they fired faster um well they could get
you from far away like a sniper
yeah well yeah well they were a little
more accurate than a [ __ ]
match lock or a flintlock they didn't
really have sights on it and they
weren't rifled
it was just you know a lead ball or a
handful of lead balls like a shotgun if
it was a musket
uh but what they did was they'd ambush
at close range with a [ __ ]
cl with a war club or a hatchet
and it was all over man they were good
real good at that [ __ ]
or it was bows and they were basically
silent well they weren't silent when
it's when it hit you because you'd
scream
but you couldn't know where they were
and it was the rate of fire
i'm just saying they did the [ __ ] from
horseback a lot of times
you know once once they figured out how
to ride horses because the spaniards
brought horses they figured that out
quick
they were just like oh convenient all
right yeah the indian indians were
players
they were players they were players in
the game
esther says uh jenny season 7 episode
11 naked and frayed was in louisiana i
thought i saw one that was in louisiana
i knew there was one that was in a swamp
i was pretty sure it was louisiana i
thought for a second it might have been
the everglades but i guess not
but yeah so that was one thing and i'm
glad somebody actually kind of brought
that up about the whole feral children
thing because
that's one thing that's why i think that
there's a lot of controversy about
certain feral children cases is because
nobody
you know as i said some of the more
famous cases they don't know how long
the kid was out there
because they just kind of stumbled
across them one day and
another thing too is just that i think
there's a lot of
controversy over whether particularly
some more modern cases
are real or not because there is kind of
an incentive
and we'll get into this a little bit
when i talk about like a more modern
case
um and i'm not saying that i disbelieve
the woman's story or anything like that
but there is maybe an incentive to
embellish this kind of stuff uh you know
sell books or whatever you want to do
so i so i don't know and and like you
said it's
it's really i'm sure it's not like
impossible
for a kid to survive but they would need
help you know whether it was from
animals or
whatever if you're just like out there
by yourself all
naked and whatever i just i don't think
a kid can make it
so the next case i want to talk about is
kind of similar to the first one this
kid was called a
victor of and i'm sure i'm pronouncing
this wrong a veyron
of veyron something like that so this
happened in the late 18th century so
right around the same time period
and this kid was about the same age he
was 11 or 12
when he was found as i said they don't
really know where he came from they
don't know how long he had been out
there
um but there there had been reports of
this kid prior
uh you know some people said hey there's
this naked kid like running around in
these woods
that's apple and coconuts real good oh
okay thanks uh there's these naked kids
running
this naked kid running around these
woods in france um you know eating
acorns and whatnot
and they finally uh captured him so they
finally went out there and captioned him
and uh they named him victor and uh you
know
because they didn't know what his name
was like i said they didn't know how
long he'd been out there
now again you know news of his capture
kind of spread really fast like in the
scientific community because they're
just like uh you know we want to study
this kid
because you know like i said this was
kind of the time period it was like
nature nurture all that kind of stuff
so they brought the kid to paris and
just like in
uh peter the wild boy's case you know
which happened in london
they brought the kid to paris and he was
you know everybody in the court wanted
to come see him and he was like a big
sensation
and everything like that and as i
mentioned earlier
it was around this time that people were
talking about
romanticism and they were talking about
john jack rousseau
and him talking about how you know man
in the state of nature
and it's like they had these ideas about
society was
you know all these uh you know
constrictions of society were not good
for
for a person like they should be able to
uh
go with their natural instincts so they
thought that finding this kid
who they believed and like i said i
don't know if this is true or not
but they believed at the time that he
had been raised without any
uh contact with society so they were
interested to see
if russo's theories would be proved
correct because they're like well this
kid should be like
you know the perfect man really because
he hasn't
had any uh contact with society
which uh russo and the other romantics
kind of thought was uh sort of harmful
because they
they kind of had the whole noble savage
they kind of like romanticized that
uh to a degree so that's kind of uh
what they were looking to
highlight uh with this kid unfortunately
um this kid when they brought him to
paris
uh he wasn't a real good example
of what they were talking about uh
because he basically just
acted like an animal he couldn't talk
um you know he would just grunt he would
eat pretty much anything he said in
front of him no matter how gross it was
uh he couldn't even the weird thing
about this too and
this happened with a couple other feral
children they found two which we'll talk
about a little bit later
but he didn't seem to have any
he he didn't really seem to have any
reactions to
stimuli like heat or cold or anything
like that like
temperature differentials didn't seem to
bother him which i thought was very
weird
um basically so i don't know if that was
because he'd been a feral kid or if he
had some other issue
um basically they said he would just sit
there and rock back and forth
and uh he just tried to stay as far away
from
humans as possible so
what ended up happening so they had like
this guy
who was a psychologist he was kind of
well known at the time
in france named philippe pannell
and his diagnosis was that
he thought the kid was just a quote
unquote incurable idiot
and that it didn't even matter that he
was that he'd been found out in the
woods or that maybe he hadn't been out
in the woods for that long he was just
like that naturally and like him being
from the woods didn't have anything to
do with it
um and he was basically saying i don't
think that he would have been
able to survive like out in the woods
for any amount of time
because of his mental impairment
however um this other doctor another
psychologist named dr ettard
um he actually took a interest in the
kid
and decided that he was going to he
didn't really adopt him but
he kind of spent pretty much a really
long time like um several hours a day
with him and he became convinced
that this kid could be taught
to read and write and do things that
ordinary
people uh would do
um so as i said it was very strange
because he really didn't seem to have
much reaction to stimuli
even kind of um extreme stimuli
like they would put snuff up his nose
and he didn't sneeze
um you know they'd have potatoes in
boiling water and he would just reach in
there and take one and it didn't seem to
like bother him
um they would like this is kind of
[ __ ] up but they would
make really loud noises like by his ear
like fire a gun or something like that
and he didn't even like flinch or
nothing he must be
deaf well they thought that but he
wasn't
because one thing that he did one sound
that he did react to
was if he cracked open walnuts because
he loved walnuts
so if you cracked open a walnut behind
him he'd be like well okay
give me walnut so that's how they knew
he wasn't deaf autistic
uh that's what they think nowadays they
didn't know what autism was back then
but um they did actually think because
like i said dr ettard had actually
worked with
uh deaf mutes yeah and so that was one
of the first things that he thought well
maybe the kid's deaf
but they they figured out that he wasn't
it's really weird because
okay so dr [ __ ] like i said he thought
he's like well this kid can be
taught right so he spent i mean
give the dude his due he spent a really
long time
uh i think it's like five years or
something like that like spending
several several hours a day
you know trying to teach this kid to
talk
and to read and understand now
after five years uh victor
he could identify a few written words
and phrases
um you know just very simple
like concepts he he understood that um
he understood like the differences
between like if you said big small
things like that like he understood that
um he had a bunch of uh
words on cards that he could like show
like when he wanted something like he
could hold the card up that had the word
on it
that said what he wanted so he could
understand like rudimentary
understanding um he actually learned to
write
a couple of uh words but only two or
three different words
one of which was the french word for
milk although they weren't entirely sure
if he was just
because at first he was saying that what
the word is as uh
late lee and um
they didn't know if he was just saying
that because he understood that that was
the word for milk or if that was just a
sound that he made for anything that he
liked you know what i mean like it was
kind of like
it wasn't real clear uh later on they
figured maybe it was maybe he did
understand what that word meant
um and i think he could like he
understood water like he understood that
but other than that he never really uh
learned to talk
and interestingly some later researchers
that looked into the case
they said that even though he wasn't
deaf they know he could hear
but they said he did react to everything
as though he was
a deaf mute and they thought it was very
interesting
that dr ettard who actually worked with
deaf mute patients wouldn't have thought
to teach the kids sign language maybe he
was so
convinced well because the kid can hear
that he should
uh you know theoretically be able to
learn to talk so maybe he was so focused
on teaching
victor to talk that it didn't occur to
him or he didn't
or he thought it was a waste of his time
to teach him sign language because that
he might have gotten farther with that i
feel like
but for whatever reason he didn't really
seem to
he was just trying to teach him to write
and to like understand written language
and to talk
and he never really did get very far
with it although the kid could
understand
a lot of commands and whatnot but he
never really
got all that good at it interestingly
though
one thing that they did teach him when
he was first found
and like for the first uh short time
they were working with him
they he didn't really seem to have any
interest
in humans at all um if other people were
around he would just ignore them like
they weren't there
uh so it was that kind of thing but
later like the longer he lived with
dr etard and um his housekeeper his name
was madame uh
guerran i guess um the longer he lived
with him the more empathy he developed
uh and the more he seemed to enjoy being
around them
and like if they were away and then they
came back like he seemed very happy to
see them
so he did eventually get to a point
where he seemed to develop some kind of
like empathy with other humans because
when they first found him he just like
had no interest in humans whatsoever
um and he would just like ignore them
whenever possible so
spending five years with that doctor did
really actually seem to help him a
little bit
um but like i said they don't i mean he
ended up dying
of pneumonia in 1828 at madame garan's
house
uh who was the housekeeper nowadays
um they're pretty sure that mate will
they don't actually know if the kid was
born
normally um or and then was abandoned or
if he was born with some kind of mental
issues and was abandoned
uh as i said they don't really know how
long he had been out in the woods
because they just kind of
there had been reports of seeing the
naked kid running around but then they
you know they found them later on but
they don't know how long you've been out
there
um they think maybe most commonly they
think maybe precocious schizophrenia
uh maybe autism you know
maybe some kind of like psychosis or
something but they're
you know they're speculating that either
he was born with some kind of mental
illness or something developed when he
was young and then he got abandoned
and then that's what happened but they
never did uh teach him how to talk
although they did under
they did teach him like some rudimentary
concepts and some rudimentary
language so there was that but like i
said he had to work with him for like
[ __ ]
five years or whatever so now this case
i want to talk to this is
actually a fairly recent case
and i kind of wanted to talk about this
one because this one is kind of
uh controversial in the sense that some
people don't really
know if this woman's making [ __ ] up or
not i'm not i'm not weighing in either
way because i don't know
i i don't know if she's making it up um
you know
her story could very possibly be true it
might not be true i don't really know
i'm not saying one way or the other
so we're talking about uh marina chapman
now i actually found an article
about her from the guardian which came
out in 2013
because she and her daughter had written
a book
about her uh childhood experiences the
book was called the girl with no name
now this woman claims
that she lived with a troupe of monkeys
for four years i think it was
from the age of five to the age of nine
in uh colombia
now this okay so
this story is this is a very interesting
story that she has
this one might be kind of like i don't
know if this might be like a little bit
long
but um go ahead let's hear it yeah so so
what ends up happening
uh and like i said she wrote a book
called the girl with no name which i've
heard is
i've read excerpts of it and it actually
sounds really uh interesting
so she says that her first memory
uh comes from shortly before her fifth
birthday she doesn't remember anything
before that she doesn't remember
her human parents um she says she
doesn't remember anything from before
she was five years old
so she says that right before she was
five years old she was playing
uh by her house and two
dudes came creeping up behind her
and put a hand over her mouth and
essentially kidnapped her
okay this was in colombia
now she got taken away
um because she said they put something
over her mouth and then like she doesn't
remember anything like they
made you know she was unconscious or
whatever so then she says she got driven
into the forest into the rainforest in
colombia
and then eventually she was dumped out
there
and just left there she said that she
thought that the people that had
kidnapped her were gonna come back for
her but they never did
um and she didn't see anybody else so
she said she just walked around
in the jungle and didn't see anyone
didn't see anything no sign of
civilization anything like that
she was like freaking out and she says
that eventually
um she came across a
troupe of little monkeys now
she said that now this is her talking
about when she was a kid
she said that she was kind of like oh
well they're not people but they're sort
of like people
like their little bitty fuzzy people she
was five and so she decided to kind of
hang out
next to the monkeys now she says the
monkeys
at first they were kind of like ignoring
her
they were just going they're doing their
thing you know grooming and
looking for food and doing what monkeys
do and they were just kind of ignoring
her
but she was kind of like hung out around
the edge of their
troop or whatever because was she was
getting good all well she was well she
was fascinated by them and she said she
looked like you know they looked like
they were having a good time and she was
alone so she just was kind of like
hanging around
now she says the monkeys didn't really
pay that much attention to her
until one day when she ate something off
a tree i think she said she thought it
was like a tamarind
kind of thing and she got food poisoning
and she started she was like really
really sick
she said now when that happened one of
the older monkeys
um kind of pulled her toward like um
where there was like some muddy water
she drank some of it and then threw up
and then she started to get better so
she said from that point forward
um the monkey sorta started hanging out
with her a little bit more stop the
monkeys taking care of her
yeah drink some of that throw it up yeah
maybe well i don't you know i don't know
that's what she was thinking
yeah i mean the monkeys maybe they know
that maybe that happens to them all the
time hey you eat a bad one of those and
start puking go over there and drink
that it's like a ipa cac
yeah you know what i mean maybe
so apparently she says from that point
forward um
and she did make this statement she's
like the monkeys she's like i never felt
like the monkeys loved me
she's like i felt more like they
tolerated me right
like you know what i mean um so she
apparently
learned to you know she's five she
learned to climb trees
um you know she learned what what she
could eat and what she couldn't eat
uh how to do grooming all this other
kind of stuff
and she said one of the first things she
figured out was that when they were
looking around for food and climbing up
in the trees and everything she said
sometimes
when they were walking around because
they're just little monkeys you know and
they have like big handfuls of bananas
and stuff and she's like they'd always
drop some
so it's like she learned to like stand
underneath them when they were like
doing this and
like yeah you know the bananas would
drop down and she would eat them
so she said it took a while but
eventually like the monkeys would
let her sit in the trees with them and
you know so she just kind of like hung
out like i said they weren't
super all over her or anything but they
were just kind of like okay you can hang
with us whatever
it was kind of like that now as i
mentioned she said she didn't really
have any
uh memory of her parents like her
biological parents
her human family prior to her being
kidnapped allegedly
um she said she's trying to remember but
she can't
so it's interesting because she wrote
this story
um and it's like i said i don't know if
i buy it because like i said it gets
even like more horrific like later on
well being raised by monkeys isn't
horrific but i'm just saying her the
story gets horrific kidnapping is
horrific
but it gets horrific later on so she
read all this in a book and like when
the book came out in 2013 there was kind
of like a big
thing about it because a lot of people
didn't believe her they thought they
just she just made this story up
um like i said i'm not making a stand on
that one way or the other it could very
well be true i have no [ __ ] idea like
crazy or [ __ ] has happened
god knows so you know what i mean
so basically because i think what
happened was that
i think later they were just kind of
like well where was it that you
you know where is this jungle where you
uh were raised by the monkeys and she
couldn't find it
but she did find some of the other
locations of [ __ ] that happened to her
later so you know i'm more inclined to
kind of believe it maybe it's
embellished but i don't know i'm not
saying
that so basically
um she said like i said they you know
they just kind of tolerated her they did
like kind of like
groom her and um you know things like
that so she caught they kind of treated
her like one of the
gang but you know not
super she said they asked her because i
was reading this interview with her that
was in the guardian and they said when
did she feel
she had been accepted by the monkeys and
she basically said when they started
pissing on her leg
[Laughter]
that's how i was like he's pissing on
you is when they accept you that sounds
about right well like i said you guys
know
um i don't know if you guys know what a
bonobo handshake is
do you know but i believe that's why you
[ __ ] what put your dick grab your
grab your dick
yeah yeah that's how that's how they be
friendly they just like stick their
their dick at you well the male ones do
obviously the female ones don't do that
but uh yeah they they stick your dick at
you and you're supposed to like kind of
shake it you know
yeah that's like that's their way of
saying hi yeah give me a hand joe
you know bonobos yeah they're like the
[ __ ] those are the hoes
they're the hoes of the animal world
okay that's like every
i was at a a zoo one time i can't
remember where it was but they had like
a big enclosure of like bonobos
it's like i was sitting there thinking
i'm sure
i'm sure they must get complaints like
every day from people like with their
kids and stuff which is like all those
monkeys do as [ __ ] i'm like well that's
kind of their thing that's what they do
that's how they resolve like
all their issues yeah they don't fight
they're just kind of like hey it's all
right just let me like
you know and it and they they don't
matter like it doesn't matter if it's
two females
two males it doesn't get they don't care
that if there's like five of them they
don't care
they're just that's how they smooth over
uh conflicts
they just you know they do sexual [ __ ]
that's just how they that's how they
roll
you know what i mean it's a mobile
[ __ ] [ __ ] band
like a bunch of porn stars yeah that's
pretty much yeah so uh so basically so
they asked her
they're like okay well what did you do
this whole time you're a jungle because
like i said she was in the jungle she
says
for i believe it was four years from the
time she was five until she was
nine years old um and she basically
just stayed with these monkeys the whole
time um and once she had learned
how to find food from the monkey she's
like that was pretty much your whole
entire existence was just you would get
up in the morning you would like go and
find food and
that's just what you would do um you
know
and she said the only thing she did like
for fun was to just like
play with other little animals like
little bugs and lizards and whatnot
um you know and just sit there and get
groomed by the monkeys and
all that other kind of [ __ ] now she said
that every now and then
she would see hunters coming through the
jungle
and she was like afraid of them because
a lot of them you know have machetes and
guns and whatever
um but she knew that they were the same
as her that they were human
so she decided one day after she had
been in the allegedly after she'd been
in the jungle for four years
she decided she was gonna ask one of
these humans for help
probably she wishes she hadn't nowadays
because you know people are the worst
but she comes up to these hunters that
she saw
uh she had no clothes obviously she had
a dress when she was kidnapped but it
had
you know obviously worn off in like the
four [ __ ] years she was
out there and she couldn't really
she had been able to talk obviously
before she
was kidnapped but she couldn't really
remember
a lot of language because she had been
in the hanging with the monkeys for four
years
so she was like basically grunting at
these hunters
so the hunters uh did rescue her
uh and then she was nine years old i
think and then they sold her into a
brothel
oh really which is nice where was this
again columbia
colombia which like i said it sounds
like a crazy story and you're like
really but i'm just like i don't know i
i kind of feel like that sounds kind of
plausible
that sounds kind of plausible that
sounds about right actually no i'd have
to see where
i don't know i don't know about this
first of all the colombian jungle is
pretty [ __ ] nasty
it is and she didn't make the complaints
i would think of the insects
she didn't say she wasn't being eaten up
by mosquitoes oh i don't know
well i mean she might have been but she
didn't mention it like i haven't read
the book i just read like how was he
sleeping
who knows yeah i'd have to hear more
about this entries well like i said i'd
have to read the whole book i'm not
making a judgment call on it
because i don't know when it sounds
fishy to me we'll see
a lot of people said that a lot of
people said that it sounded fishy to me
i mean she sounds
so easy i've seen a couple documentaries
and she seems like a lovely woman
and she doesn't seem like she's
bullshitting she doesn't seem like she's
making it up
but hold on let me go get a wig you're
gonna
let me get away you gotta get a wig to
think about this i gotta get i can think
about this i need a wig
[Laughter]
is is that gonna help you yeah yeah
thank
yeah this whole i spent i'm nine years
old
i'm living out in the woods for three
for four years the monkeys [ __ ]
help me survive
i ain't buying that man monkeys aren't
gonna help you that much
it takes more than monkeys yeah
and uh i think i would have heard
more complaints of a lot more problems
than just
oh well they pissed on my leg nah i'm
saying but i don't think i'm buying this
well like i said
i don't know because i haven't read the
book she might have been
she might have talked about stuff more
extensively yeah okay
because i'm just i just read like a
couple articles about her and saw like a
short documentary
um so like i said i don't know she like
talked a lot more about it i'm sure she
talked about it in more a lot more depth
like in the book or whatever
that's poster down says that's tom's
thinking wig
it makes you more sexy it makes me more
sexy
rusty says i'm going to read the book i
probably will too it sounds like
actually really interesting
i don't know if i buy it even if it's
not true
it might still be a good story i you
know what i'm more inclined i just okay
so the thing about it though
is that you can write a book
about um you know hey i got kidnapped
and
dumped in the woods and then i lived
with a troop of monkeys for four years
i feel like you could write a whole book
about that
i feel like maybe why people are
freaking out is that not only did she
have that in the book like
i lived with monkeys for four years but
then after i was rescued
from the monkeys i ended up in a brothel
and then
well she ran away from the brothel right
how long was you the brothel not that
long
and she ran away from the brothel and
then she was like um
then she ended up homeless like living
on the streets
and then um she basically had to become
like a pickpocket
like to make money right and um
then she ended up working as
a domestic like in a household and then
like the the daughter of that person
that she worked for like ended up
adopting her
you know what i mean this just sounds
like an awful tall tale because these
are all pretty sophisticated skills
that you have to have one right after
another and i don't know if a feral
person
can just pull some [ __ ] like this out of
her ass like one minute she's in the
jungle
with the monkeys the next the next
minute she's with frankenhooker out
there turning tricks and [ __ ]
and then she's a pickpocket and then she
ends up being a maid
it's just you know and she was only 14
at this point when she got adopted
when she got adopted my wig on straight
where's that
where's the part uh where's the part
like right there is it in the middle no
not really wait which way has got to go
like oh like no make sure i'm pretty
there we go make sure
make sure i'm pretty there you go
there's another shirt
i'm just going to show you i'm going to
put tom's face on there with the wig and
just
say make sure i'm pretending i'm going
full heavy metal right now
heavy metal god yeah you're [ __ ]
right just ask tila tila i'm a [ __ ]
heavy metal god but i got this all right
right yeah there you go yeah you gonna
talk about getting raised by monkeys you
do actually
talk i'm gonna talk about getting raised
by dancing
[Laughter]
you do look like i was raised by dancing
which in a way probably in a lot of ways
is worse than getting raised by black
yeah
yeah yeah you know danzig don't flush
the toilet
i'm sure he doesn't no he totally does
not seem like someone that's a dude that
[ __ ] drops
drops of [ __ ] crap forget the fish
and just [ __ ] walks away
and then you walk in there later you're
like [ __ ] man
and he's like flush it
yeah it's kind of what he is i saw his
old house i know he's like that
said man his motherfucker's house bro
dude don't flush a toilet
yeah that's a very specific thing but i
don't know yeah yeah yeah exactly what
you're talking about i know
i know what you're talking about psychic
psychic energy told me this
oh my god yeah
just white trash maximum white dress
maximum white dress
turned up to 11. yeah yeah so yeah so i
was saying so
so yeah she she was in the brothel well
she got sold into a brothel and then she
ran away from the brothel and then she
was like on the street as a pickpocket
and then she worked in the maid and then
she got when she was 14 she got adopted
and then victor said and then she was
spotted by a modeling agency and yeah i
was a model in new york city her first
day of the job 9 11.
yeah yeah yeah it's yeah it is kind of
like that's what i mean if you're going
to
just a pro tip if you're gonna because i
know that there was kind of a trend
for people writing literary fiction or
kind of like a story and this like oh
this will sell much better if i say that
it's autobiography if it's a true story
like you know what i mean because who
was that dude that wrote a million
little pieces and he was like all over
oprah and he sold like a zillion books
and they found out that the story was
[ __ ]
um yeah jane what was the dude's name my
camera's name i remember the title of
the book but i can't remember the
dude's name was so i feel like it was
kind of like a trend because everybody
loves based on a true story right and
everybody loves
autobiographies of people that had
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] happen to them
so i can see how if you're a writer and
you have this really good idea for a
story
if you say hey this really happened to
me
then that's going to obviously sell a
lot better than just like another
fictional ass story right
so a lot of people did that i'm not
saying this woman did that
i'm not like i said i'm not making a
judgment this very well could have
happened
crazier [ __ ] has happened okay i'm not
saying that
i'm just saying that if
per chance you're a writer and you want
to make a zillion dollars and you want
you do your [ __ ] in the oprah book club
and everything like that
and you have this really cool idea for a
story and you decide hey i'm going to
make this like it happened to me even
though it totally didn't
like just reign it in a little bit it's
got to be crazy
and salacious and everything so people
want to read it
but like that book civil but you can't
compound
the craziness like i said just being
raised by monkeys for four years when
you're a kid that's crazy enough that's
enough
yeah um if she had stopped there
probably no one would be questioning it
i think the fact that people i mean why
people are questioning it is probably
because
i got rescued from the monkeys and then
i got sold into a brothel and then i was
a pickpocket on the streets and
blah blah blah so it's just the more you
compound it like the less believable it
seems and like i said i'm not saying
that it didn't happen because it very
well may have
i'm just saying that just
you know if you're going that route then
just like
it's like that book sybil remember the
book civil yeah woman with all the
multiple personality disorder
james frye thank you i knew it was james
something yeah then she was talking
about [ __ ] that her mom did
and everything i kind of believed it at
the time but [ __ ] later on
later on by by the time the late 80s and
the 90s were rolling around i was like
man this is this is [ __ ]
this didn't happen and that's the thing
it's like it's really hard because
i can't you can't discount anybody's
like even if it's kind of crazy i mean
unless it's like supernatural [ __ ] like
hey they flushed us down the toilet and
like chuck norris was there like the
satanic panic [ __ ]
like that's obviously [ __ ] but um
but i mean something that could still
happen because crazy [ __ ] happens to
people crazy [ __ ] happens the world i
get that
um you know it's rare but it does happen
so i
really don't like to like discount
anybody's story completely out of hand
but you know the
chances of several
uh you know crazy things happening to
you
in quick succession like that is
infinitesimally small
imagine that though you're at daycare
you and your friends
right they they're grabbing me and my
boy
and they stuff us in the toilet and
flush us down the toilet and we
end up in a room and chuck norris is
there
and every what's up what the hell it
didn't work she jumped up on her oh my
god
yeah you're all right chuck norris is
there and then they all get away in a
balloon
yeah that's how that story went it would
have been better if they'd flown away on
a dragon
yeah y'all left in a big old [ __ ] hot
air balloon
yeah that's some [ __ ] bro i mean there
should have been an immediate acquittal
there those people were in [ __ ]
prison for
i mean as soon as somebody said that out
loud everyone should have been like all
right let's go home
this is just like a waste of time from
this point forward those poor people
that worked at that but no
i know and it's like i feel really bad
yeah it's just like
okay stop [ __ ] around this is what
she did listen to your father
she's she's not with them yeah she tried
to jump up there and like she just like
she slipped
there was nothing to there was nothing
to grab onto she was like oh no
you're all right though is she all right
yeah i can't see her she's just
embarrassed
oh she got embarrassed by that nobody
saw it poke it's fine yeah
we just told everybody about it right
she's yeah she does look like all
embarrassed she's like trying to play it
off like
i see you you guys didn't see that right
but yeah so
so she gets adopted uh when she's 14 she
goes to live in
bogota and i guess what ended up
happening was that
the family that adopted her they were
like in the textile industry
so they ended up sending her to um
bradford in england and she went to
school there and when she lived there
like she met the guy that would become
her husband later and then they had a
bunch of kids
and i guess that like her daughter
vanessa
was the one who wanted who she actually
started writing
her mom's story and they say well it's
like we weren't actually
thinking about publishing it at first we
were just kind of like writing it for
you know family edification or whatever
because she said i didn't really
she's like i told them some of the [ __ ]
but i didn't really tell them a lot of
it
you know what i mean but they were kind
of saying that
when she was younger um you know she
would do kind of weird
things like she had a hard time they
said she had a hard time
doing like little things like opening
doors and stuff because it's like they
didn't really have doors in the jungle
so it's just kind of like she had a hard
time with that
like she liked to climb trees she liked
to run around on all fours
all that other kind of stuff and they
didn't really think anything about it at
the time until like she told them
what the deal was later on um and she
says
she says in the interview that actually
for a long time she was kind of like
embarrassed about it
because when they saved her because like
not only did she grow up with monkeys
but also then that was the whole brothel
situation then she was homeless and
stuff
so she had to be taught she says how to
like you know use a toilet and how to do
other things like that and she found
that very embarrassing
so it was that whole issue
um now she eventually ended up
now like i said because she was
allegedly five when she was
kidnapped and could already talk and
everything
they were able to actually if this all
of this did happen
they were actually able to get her back
she's completely normal
she can talk she can read she can do all
that kind of stuff she's not
impaired in any way she actually ended
up
training as a chef and works at
bradford's national media museum as a
chef um
you know so she and like i said she
married she had kids the kids had kids
so she has grandkids
and um they ended up writing this book
in 2013
and you know there's a lot of articles
kind of calling into question all of the
stuff
she did she could never find the part of
the jungle where she lived with the
monkeys
but she apparently did find the brothel
where she lived
and the um the family that adopted her
obviously they
corroborate that part of her story
that's probably where the story started
so
maybe i don't know yeah that's probably
i don't know um
i don't know she's just saying like i
said she seems like a lovely
person she seems like a nice lady okay
um so i don't really know
i don't really know if it's true or not
i don't know i wasn't there
doesn't sound true to me it sounds a
little far-fetched i will say that
um although how cool would it be to get
to hang out with little monkeys and they
like groom you and bring you bananas and
stuff
i believe it that'd be so rad i mean
that would be red right yeah not four
years out there yeah see that's the
thing if it
if it was just like not that long a time
a couple months
maybe maybe four years four years i
don't know
columbia i don't know colombia's got
some intense [ __ ] jungle
victor said she could just she could
just walk to a random tree in the jungle
and be like this is where i grew up
yes i know she's totally good it's like
no one can prove otherwise
colombia's got a hell of a [ __ ] like
rainforest action going there it's just
not
it's not [ __ ] it's hostile
environment
uh yeah i ain't buying it
not four years now that equipment not
without training
no no someone killed her
i mean you would think yeah she'd been
eating to death by [ __ ] big bugs
i mean at the very least yeah phil says
sorry i'm late catching up on college
work that's okay we're still here
phil also says hey daddy tom and
beautiful jen i'm still pretty
yeah you are also beautiful tom
t said i'm the king of all [ __ ] heavy
metals
you know it's really really creepy how
much you look like a young glen danzig
when you have that weight yeah
yeah or like like like the [ __ ] lead
singer of the co
a little bit yeah you need a hat for
that though you need like that weird and
you need like some velvet
like some crushed velvet vest or some
[ __ ] like yeah
tied around my head and [ __ ] there you
go yeah
little pointed boots yeah you could
totally does a big fluffy like white
shirt
uh but yeah so so marina like uh
apparently has been trying to find her
birth parents
and is kind of hoping that she said that
was one of the reasons she wrote the
book because she wanted to figure out
her birth parents were because like i
said
prior to the monkey family she didn't
actually remember her human family and
uh so she was like trying to find them
like i said i do not know if this story
is [ __ ] or not um
i kind of hope the monkey part is true
not the brothel part because that would
kind of suck
but and not the kidnapping part that
also sucks but the monkey part is is
pretty cool
so i wish it was true i don't know if it
is though so
all right so the next one i want to talk
about is
i might have to maybe i should uh run to
the
back
first like before i like while i'm in
between cases you know what i mean
go ahead okay we don't have any
commercials we got to play out
no we got nothing i do okay i'll keep
everybody company
i'll keep everybody comfy with my
[ __ ] hair and [ __ ] so what is
everybody up to
go ahead drop a comment down in the
comment section
[ __ ] esther says all hail tom danzig
yeah [ __ ] filmer says i'm beautiful
of course i'm beautiful
all right she said no i'm raised by
monkey yeah
i think that story began with the
brothel probably
but uh difficult to say
man let's see what this shit's [ __ ]
itching me man
itching my eyelashes
i almost thought about going to the club
tonight
i think the show's gonna be going on too
long though for us to go to the club
we'll see
see what time it is right now let's see
yeah it's 8 12. and she's probably got
another hour at least
yeah i'm only beautiful with the wig on
when i got the wig off i don't become
beautiful anymore i get ugly
ugly ass [ __ ] cue ball head look like
lex luthor
what's up jenny i was talking about
maybe we'll go to the club tonight
10 o'clock oh my god yeah
how much is left on the show we're
halfway through at least it looks like
yeah
i mean everybody's going to be there god
damn it
we don't have to go we don't have to go
we have to do this two days again as
well yeah
oh my god you don't have to go you're
gonna kill me
i'm not killing you trying to kill me
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] biology
it's it's not biology that's all that
[ __ ] it's all those it's all those
[ __ ] uh
hormones exogenous [ __ ] hormones man
i don't know i'll i'll see how i feel
but yeah i feel i mean i kind of wanted
to rest but
cause we got to go we're going out
tomorrow right yep tomorrow night
and it's like you know friday's the best
night for mannequins i know
but it's like i don't have a [ __ ] ton of
money either i got money i mean the
thing about it is that
i don't know nobody's got a [ __ ] ton of
buddy but you know
if we had millions that would be a [ __ ]
time well yeah that'd be nice
yeah don't think you're thinking about
it too much just go
i know you're thinking about it too much
what else that's my thing
yeah she's overthinking things you know
that right yeah it's like
no amount of you telling me is gonna
like change that because it's like then
i'm to overthink that
yeah that you're telling me that so
you're just you're really kind of
shooting yourself in the foot
i'm just kidding guys this is a new
documentary on youtube about leonard
lake and charles name
oh boneyard man oh man i'm gonna have
that [ __ ] case is one of the worst
man that's going to make me so mad
that case bothers me well yeah
right i'll probably end up having to
watch that anyway you know how i do
all right so the next one i want to talk
about
is a dude named dina sanishar
now this guy was reportedly the dude
that
uh mowgli from the jungle book was based
on
so this guy was apparently raised by
wolves
in uh india hunters found him in 1867
and brought him to
an orphanage so what ends up happening
so the hunters
are in this uh jungle
and in india as i mentioned so they come
across a clearing
and then at the one end of the clearing
there's like a cave like a cave entrance
and they thought at first when they
glanced at it they said it looked like
a wolf sitting there like a wolf sitting
in front of the cave entrance
so they kind of got close to it they
were going to kill it
and they kind of get close to it but
then they realized
that it wasn't a wolf it was a kid and
if this kid was
six years old now he just like sat there
and looked at them
um they asked him like hey what the [ __ ]
kid i'm you know i'm speculating
yeah uh but he didn't answer them so
they were like okay well this is a human
kid obviously so we need to take this
kid back to human civilization
so they bring him to an orphanage in
agra
now he didn't have a name obviously uh
so they named him dina sanishar
uh which i guess that was the word for
saturday
like in the hindi language because that
was the day that they found him on
uh and they also called him wolf boy
because of course they did um because
like i said
it was a wolf they think that that was
uh the cave was where the wolves were
staying and that he'd been raised by
wolves
and he also acted kind of like a wolf
like he uh
couldn't really stand on two feet he ran
around on all fours
and he would only eat raw meat so you
know there's that
um apparently they like i said they
weren't
sure because they just found him there
but he didn't really seem to have ever
had any contact with humans in his life
he was not
familiar with any kind of human behavior
human language anything like that
um he he would also like
gnaw on bones like to keep his teeth
sharp uh you know like an animal would
and uh so basically and and they would
he would like
like i said he would only raw meat and
he would always like smell it before he
ate it just like an animal
and he uh would basically just
growl um or do like wolf howls
stuff like that he didn't really seem to
be able to talk
they tried to do sign language to him
but he didn't understand that either
um he also didn't understand pointing
like if you pointed at something it's
like he didn't uh like an animal
yeah he didn't understand that either um
at some point like they kind of worked
to them for a while at the
you know with the orphanage they said he
did actually eventually
learn to understand
what their gist was he didn't learn to
talk
um but he did kind of like sort of
understand what they wanted
um and they said too that he also
really got into smoking what
smoking yeah they said they i i don't
know whose idea it was as he
didn't get a cigarette he's like hey
give the kid a cigarette and he's like
oh okay
i like that and he's just like well yeah
he's like give me that and he really got
into it yeah
he probably didn't inhale maybe not he
just thought it was like kind of neat i
don't know what it was
so uh apparently yeah so his case was uh
discussed in a lot of different
um books and a lot of journals at the
time which like i said they think that's
where rudyard kipling got the idea for
uh mowgli in the jungle book
and the weird thing about it though see
and here's another thing
a lot of these cases now particularly in
india i'm not sure why
exactly but particularly in india there
have been a lot of lot of cases
of kids raised by wolves
i mentioned the amala and kamala case
earlier
the the wolf girls or whatever and
they've they're pretty sure that that's
a fraud
and it's interesting because a lot of
the orphanages that said that they had
these kids that had been raised by
wolves and they found them in
you know wolf dens or they found them
out in the woods or whatever um came
from missions came from like
church-based
uh orphanages so there has been some
speculation that for whatever reason
um these orphanages are trying to
draw up publicity or for whatever reason
they're saying that they have all these
wolf kids because
you know danny sanishar even though he's
kind of like one of the better known
ones
um there were a lot of other orphanages
in that area
actually even that same orphanage that
he was at that
had other kids that had supposedly been
raised by wolves this same orphanage
said they had two other boys
and one girl who also supposedly had
been raised by wolves
and i don't know that seems a little
again far-fetched yeah so they're doing
that they're doing a whole wolf motif
it's a motif yeah yeah and
apparently it got to a point like in
this area of india
uh this one geographer said i found this
[ __ ] great quote
it says this orphanage took in so many
wolf children over the years
that they no longer even looked up when
another kid was discovered in the jungle
uh and that says it created no more
surprise than the delivery of the daily
supply of butcher's meat hey
here's another wolf kid oh another one
yawn
can you imagine i ain't buying it yeah i
kind of uh
i'm kind of not buying it either that's
that's very nice that's a nice
little elvis wig there
[Laughter]
just it's just another form of me
not do with the elves i came up with
this myself
did you really yeah you just sprouted
that hair looks like a pompadour
yeah just generic pompadour yeah right
yeah yeah so uh unfortunately
dana sanishar a wolf boy he died when he
was only 35
years old in 1895. he died of
tuberculosis
um didn't have anything to do with the
smoking they introduced him to so you
know
but like i said the other wolf kids not
so much this guy was like a little more
uh documented
but i'm not sure about the other ones
yeah maybe the first one there might
have been something to it but i got to
tell you you know when you when you look
at
india they're into gimmicks [ __ ] years
and [ __ ] you know i mean wise men and
supernatural [ __ ] they they have a long
history of trying to make a buck off of
a [ __ ]
strange angle you know yeah going down
to their little street performers and
stuff so i think maybe
maybe they found one wolf kid
and and they said hey that's a good idea
yeah let's do that again
that guard that that garnered some
attention and some money so that he says
well you know what we
we need more wolf kids because people
want to love the wolf kids
if one of them brings in a thousand
rupees a year the [ __ ] four of them
will bring in
4 000 rupees a year so let's go ahead
and do that you know that
it'd be so the wolf kid became a
business model
you know that's that's that's how india
rolls
well it's just kind of like you know one
shark movie makes a whole bunch of money
so let's make 40.
getting more and more ridiculous as we
go i get it
everyone's trying to get a piece of the
not about it's not so much about
original contents about riding a wave
[Laughter]
kind of the same everywhere all right so
let's talk about this other one now how
long have we been on two hours and twice
okay it's not really it's only two and a
half hours two and a half hours
i think i have wait a minute one
two three four okay so i only have a
couple more
well like four more but not they're not
long all right
all right so let's talk about this kid
marcos
rodriguez pantoja
now he was actually born in spain uh
in cordoba and then he emigrated with
his parents to
madrid now his mom died in childbirth
uh not when she was giving birth to him
but when she was giving birth to her
fourth kid and that kid also died now
marcos was three years old
at the time of his mother's death now
his
dad married uh again
and this stepmother had a kid from a
previous marriage
now the stepmother just like in the
fairy tales was evil as [ __ ]
um and started abusing marcos
like i said he was only three years old
so the 1950s
they go to um this other uh town that
i'm not even
gonna begin to pronounce and uh
started working like for a coal
manufacturing thing like the family did
so 1954 marcos had endured
like a lot of abuse in his family mostly
at the hands of his stepmother
he was seven years old and he got sent
off
some say sold to a local uh
landowner like to work as kind of like a
goat herder
like an apprentice to a goat herder um
he was basically sold into indentured
servitude
when was it in 1954 1954. spain
yeah so uh
i guess i don't know if the goat herder
or the landowner or something they just
like didn't like him or they moved away
or whatever but at some point the kid
got abandoned
in the wilderness he was found
uh in 1965 and apparently he had lived
in the wilderness
uh or at least lived by himself in
isolation for 11 years
um and he was also lived around wolves
thank you victor this is an interesting
topic good show well thank you very much
thank you very much i don't know why
i don't know why i didn't think of it
until now oh you gotta do the elvis
point
thank you very much it's not elvis it's
just my
own natural chad chad
yeah chatting it just happens that it
just happens automatically chat energy
yeah uh yeah okay so
basically they take the kid into custody
they said that he
howled uh that was the only noise that
he could make that he held like a wolf
uh you know and also kind of like bit
people and whatnot like an animal would
so uh they took him to a hospital
and they actually were able to teach him
to uh talk again and to
sort of like you know wear clothes and
walk upright and stuff like i said he
you know he was seven when he was
abandoned
uh allegedly so he already knew how to
talk and all that stuff
so i kind of feel like that's if you
were older i guess when you were
abandoned otherwise you already knew how
to talk even if you like kind of forgot
how to talk because you were out there
for such a long time it's much easier to
like reteach you
than teach you from scratch obviously so
it's mostly the ones that
were older when they were abandoned that
were able to be
rehabilitated to some degree so uh
he um basically
mostly like integrated back into society
they kind of like i said they
they kind of re-taught him how to talk
and like you know he wore clothes and
everything and they
uh he went to uh and then he lived in a
hostel
there and he actually joined the
military leader
and uh became a pastor now the sad thing
though
because people are the worst is that
because
i mean he seemed to have like normal
intelligence and they like i said they
did
he could talk and hold the job and
everything but because he had lived so
long
in isolation he was very um
naive so he got uh scammed
all the time because he was too i guess
he was too trusting or he didn't realize
that people were like [ __ ] him over
uh so they said that happened to him a
lot
so basically he kind of moved around a
lot
um and he ended up living with
um this nice dude named manuel lozada
who was a retired police officer
and um he ended up uh you know
basically like taking care of the kid
for a long time and then um
that guy died and then marcos moved to
like with a dutch family and uh so it
seems like at this point
everyone's kind of
looking after him you know what i mean
which is good um
and he is able to talk about his
experiences so he actually does go
around giving talks about
you know about uh his experiences and
stuff
so he was actually a little bit more of
a success story i guess
so they did a documentary about him
which
um i think it was called it's called
among wolves in english
i can't remember what the spanish name
was antalobos maybe
something like that um and he's kind of
in that
and then he also gave an interview in
2018
in which he said and this is what i was
referring to before
he said that um he was quote
disappointed in human nature
and wished he could return to the
mountains and leave society
so he's like yeah pretty much [ __ ] this
[ __ ] so you know he lived like out by
himself like in the wilderness with
wolves
apparently um but he's not a big fan
it doesn't sound human society this
actually doesn't sound true to me but
whatever
[Laughter]
he comes in he's raised by wolves but
then he ends up
going into the army well later well like
i said he was older when he was
abandoned
okay he was seven or eight all right it
wasn't like he was abandoned like as a
little bitty kid
so he could talk yeah yeah okay so he
already knew language he's not quite a
feral kid then
that's what i mean yeah well he's still
countered as one because he did live
apparently he did live in isolation for
like 11 years that's what they're
counting but he was older
but he was older i wouldn't call him a
feral kid when he was abandoned
to me a feral kid they can't even talk
well yeah
because they were abandoned so young so
young that they can't be [ __ ]
homeless kid yeah this this kid they did
you know because he was older they
they were actually able to uh
rehabilitate him
so then i saw a video kid that
he was from uh alabama
and he left home at about 15 and just
lived out in the woods
until he was about 20 and he had a
little [ __ ] shack made that he
he had hatchets and [ __ ] and he was
just squatting you know i think it was
on
in a park like a national park or on
masonite land we owned by
owned by a lumber company and he lived
like he was living in the [ __ ]
1800s um now is that a feral kid
no i don't think it is it's just a
homeless kid living out in the woods
yeah and he started with just a hatchet
but he was fully equipped living a good
life you know
yeah he was on youtube it is kind of
different like feral kid like you said
that's when you talk about a feral kid
you're more talking about
that no yeah that hasn't had any human
interaction
like you know for a substantial part of
their childhood yeah to a point where
they can't be rehabilitated
not quite the same i think the kid i'm
talking about he was on youtube
all the girls were talking about how
cute he was he was about 14 or 15 when
he left
and he had his own little like log cabin
and
he was fishing and just doing [ __ ] that
[ __ ] country people do
really you know it was like something
you'd see from the 1800s
but he would also go and he eventually
got older he would go and work
in town to make some money but then he'd
go back to his little shack out there
you know and what are you gonna call him
a feral kid too
i don't think so yeah just some dude
living in a shack
you know yeah yeah like you said there's
you know there's some gray area there
right yeah it's not exactly
not exactly the same yeah um
so the next one i want to talk about
this is the one that uh that you were
mentioning earlier
this is uh aksana malaya yeah her
uh who was ukrainian
is ukrainian she's still alive uh she
was born in 1983 she was the one that
was quote unquote raised by dogs
um now her kind of thing okay so she was
born
in 83 as i mentioned in a village in the
ukraine which i'm not even going to
begin to pronounce
now apparently according to her medical
records i don't think sure enough but
the medical records say
that she was normal at birth so she
didn't have any mental
disabilities nothing like that however
uh her parents or at least her father
was an alcoholic
and they basically uh neglected her
so what she did starting when she was a
toddler
was that because she was not getting any
attention or
affection from her parents she would go
out
into the kennel and would sleep with the
dogs
um and just started acting like the dogs
so she would run around on all fours and
bark and
you know act like a dog so
this went on for uh
more than four years and
she was eventually found by the
authorities
when she was seven and a half years old
and at this stage
she couldn't talk she couldn't do
a lot of stuff that a normal seven and a
half year old kid should be able to do
um basically acted like a dog uh ran
around on all fours barked
slept on the floor um ate raw food eight
like a dogwood you know hold on what if
you guys enjoy the show go ahead and
give this show a like please like share
subscribe
give jenny some flash bulbs send her
some money give drop a super chat in
[ __ ] it'd be nice to see some money
start rolling in your hair is like
very it's very distracting
jenny could always use a few tips go
ahead jenny quick just plug and plug it
because i always forget to plug the show
yeah you do yeah i always forget to
publish it yeah so uh at this point
obviously the authorities are horrified
uh so they take her
away from her uh parents and put her in
the social services
system so she gets sent to a foster home
uh with some other mentally disabled
children
now at this point at least like they did
seem to
try to help her uh she went through a
lot of therapy uh
you know a lot of education like to
figure out
what was going on with her thank you
victor here jenny thank you very much
victor's always paying thank you tom
yeah that was the biggest fun in the
whole goddamn show
laptops and everything that's not true
yeah that's not true yeah
um all right so you know we have
we have lots of people yeah yeah we have
lots of yeah but victor is kind of just
missing
he's kind of one of the highest one of
our main dudes she's one of our main
people yeah
um so she kind of she grew into
adulthood you can actually see this girl
she's kind of one of the more famous
thank you tila
roman roll and rolling thank you very
much there you go jenny interesting show
thank you thank you very much
i thought it was asking you shall
receive i'm just i'm glad that we
actually were
sort of mostly able to stay on topic
which is actually pretty cool and i'm
loaded i'm [ __ ] going sideways and
everything i'm [ __ ]
really yeah i'm holding up i'm all right
i'm holding on i'm all right
i'm hoping that you know when the show
is over at maybe about take a shower and
change my clothes
i'd be ready to go out if you wanted to
we'll see we'll see we'll see how it
goes
like i said i don't have that much thank
you esther thank you no stress jenny
no stress yeah yeah thank you very much
everybody i'll roll in there i try not
to stretch i forget i forget to plug the
show people i don't need to be a [ __ ]
douche bag and say where's the goddamn
money
i forget to plug the show we forget to
plug [ __ ] we even forget to plug
books and all kinds of other stuff well
i just get all tied up in the [ __ ]
thank you phil
this is when you go out anytime have a
drink on me thank you very much
yeah i mean we might go out tonight we
might go out tomorrow night we'll say
we'll feel we might go out both nights
and then i'll just have to spend two or
three days recovering because i'm old
but you know what i mean that's what
happens when you're old kids
you can't let go that's what we did last
weekend it was fun but man i was [ __ ]
tired
yeah yeah so with all my exogenous
hormones i'm indestructible i can
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] all
[ __ ] night long yeah but you you also
like sleep halfway
half day which i don't snore and then
yeah you wake me up snoring and then i
have to work all day
i sleep i cook
i work out i do the show
i go to the club that's it yeah i need
to get out of that habit because there's
[ __ ] i got to do around the house man
yeah there is yeah okay what's this say
thank you david june have another drink
thank you
thank you very much i got motorcycles
and [ __ ] i got to work on yeah oh you
know what i
i put down the poison oh good yeah i was
wondering if you were going to yes
it's summer we're going to get like
roaches i spr i poisoned the entire
outside of the house all the ways in all
the entrances into the house
i didn't do the kitchen i'm going to do
the kitchen later i'm always scared with
that poison in the cats
yeah i don't really like having it
inside they don't really
seem interested in it because we've done
it before
oh thank you jeffy art thank you very
much i like his little jumpy up and down
little pear guy
and phil says i plan on becoming a
patron next month oh that'd be great
yeah that'd be cool
no pressure but you will get shirts on a
pretty regular basis
we try to do it quarterly sometimes it's
a little bit late but yeah because we're
matter of fact i just got a message from
one of our uh people
in um australia australia that said that
they just got the shirt
okay yeah we just sent that out yeah we
just said that yeah yeah cause remember
that's that's who we're sending it to
when we right to the
uh yeah yeah evidently they love it
awesome
i'm gonna come up with a couple new
designs too we're gonna get some new
[ __ ]
yeah i gotta get around to that yeah i'm
gonna be paramilitary i'm gonna give you
a unit shirt
from [ __ ] first 327 recon tiger force
sure only badasses can wear that there's
only 45 dudes in tiger force at any one
time if you're not a badass and you wear
it you will explode it will explode
and that was my citation needed that was
my old recon unit there's only 45 dudes
at any one time
they're the most decorated platoon in
the whole [ __ ] army
and also the platoon that was under the
most investigation for war crimes
for vietnam at least but no there were
no convictions made but i'm gonna tell
you
the [ __ ] that they're talking about that
did happen they were [ __ ]
cutting people's heads off and doing all
that kind of stuff they were out
they were out vc'ing the vc and they
were ordered to do so by the cia
but that's another story great tila says
we should do a phantasm shirt yeah
see i i it was uh matt max mcv
sog had a lot to do with what we're
doing go and we wore tiger striped camo
so i'm one of the few dudes that still
kind of by tradition
authorized to wear tiger stripe but go
ahead i got some tiger stripes jenny saw
it
go ahead and then he keeps talking
yeah like you want to go out or not yeah
okay well don't let me talk okay
well maybe we'll see when it's over once
i freshen up and everything i'll see how
i feel he's got to freshen up i gotta go
and i gotta come down off of this you
know i mean i want to drive
well yeah i mean we don't have to go far
but it's close
yeah it's close at least it's close and
there's not any traffic really
and hopefully a lot of this will wear
off by the time it happens well yeah you
would think
yeah well like i said we don't have to
get there at any specific time they're
open till [ __ ] three in the morning
and
yeah and and everybody's gonna be there
and it's cheap
it's cheap that's true is it possible to
screen print stuff onto a cat collar
probably but it'd be hard no you can't i
mean you can't it's
it's very very small too small i mean
depending on what would be better is to
like
we could we could have something made
like a full-color
pen like one of those little enamel pens
metal and enamel
that could be pinned into a cat collar
like so oh yeah like a little
like a yes it would be like an emblem
yeah i can make one of those
yeah there's probably a company that we
can get where we can make a little well
i know yeah i know i can make one of
those yeah we'll take that and
pin it somehow permanently or uh
or screw it in there with a bolt
and into a cat collar yeah i could get
some
leather cat collars i can make i i'm
good at leather craft i could make a
collar
but the problem is it's very
labor-intensive it'd be better
to buy a decent quality breakaway cat
collar that we could put that emblem in
it could possibly hang like a pendant
well that's kind of what i was thinking
yeah okay
i mean i'm pretty sure there's like
because i mean zazzle or something like
that might have something like that too
yeah i was just i was gonna say do you
guys have you guys heard of um
those little uh round crystals that you
put over your cat's tail like to hang
over their butthole yeah the bubble
cover
yeah weird [ __ ] i don't know who would
come up with something like that some
mainly fixated [ __ ] why would
anybody want to cover up little cat
bottles
yes butthole stop looking at the cat's
bow what cat buttholes are cute
yeah i mean i know they stick them in
your face all the time yeah
yeah you're sleeping in the [ __ ] cats
they're laying down next to you and they
put the ass right and you move the ass
and they're offended
why are you moving me oh my god the
other day you guys i was playing with
her in the closet
and i was like i was petting her and
everything and my toe like accidentally
poked her in the butt
oh she was fierce and she was like so
offended like she goes
she went like that like which is the
sound she makes when she's mad and then
she looked and i came down like that and
i was like i'm sorry polka i'm sorry i
didn't mean it i'm sorry and she looked
at me
and she went like on my nose
and i was like okay i had that guy yeah
you kicked me in the ass
like i didn't need to yeah but she it
was well it
she didn't hit me right away she just
looked at me like she had her little
eyebrows were like that and she was like
and then she goes slowly bam
i want to thank everybody for those
super chats thank you victor thanks
everybody bro yeah you guys are awesome
you guys are awesome
yeah so we're talking about a dog girl
right yeah yeah pookie is hilarious she
is actually hilarious
i can't believe she came in here and
tried to jump on that fell off poor baby
she was just like oh well i'm
embarrassed she's long out
but yeah so uh yeah so they're trying to
uh rehabilitate this girl because like i
said she kind of acts like a dog she's
been living with dogs uh
for four and a half years um
they actually as she got older with
therapy and everything they were
actually able to
get her to stop acting so much like a
dog um
she did actually learn to talk and they
got her a job
at a farm uh with animals she milks cows
and stuff
but she's still not entirely
right somebody asked for pins to put on
baseball caps
oh okay there may be another thing a lot
of you guys have
a lot of guys are buying tactical caps
like i got some
condor tactical caps that come with hook
and loop attachments
there may be a way where i can make a
hook and loop emblem
that could go on a tactical cap like a
condor or something like that
maybe even like uh cryptic i don't know
if some of you guys know
you will make a tactical hook and loop
patch some of you guys might like that
that'll go on
on a combat shirt or to go on a hat or
you know whatever your play carrier
you guys know what i'm talking about go
ahead oh louie just arrived oh dude
hey there what's up what's up louie i
know
we've been on almost three hours at this
point but yeah
so uh so actually like i said she did
learn to talk
uh she did learn to not act so much like
a dog
um but they never did
she's still kind of uh impaired a little
bit
uh she does actually hold a job on a
farm um
and you know from all accounts she seems
like a lovely person but
most people uh you know most people that
have examined her said
uh because she was so neglected
and because she grew up around dogs
basically her story because they've
interviewed her so like i said she can
talk and everything
um she basically said well she wasn't
getting any
attention or affection from her parents
when she was
you know three four five years old uh so
she just crawled out to the
um channel and uh lived with the dogs
she just slept with the dogs and ate
with them and just hung out with them
and tell me the dog's name was gator oh
don't look that up i don't even know if
that's online anymore
somewhere oh it's everywhere it's
somewhere good boy gator
i mean now everyone's like oh no now
everyone's intrigued
okay yeah some cute girl jumped in a
damn kettle with a dog and dog was named
gator and [ __ ] she was nude the
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] mounted her and did
the whole nine yards and she's like my
god gator god that was fun
yeah she's she had the camera set up and
everything and that [ __ ] ended up online
nobody expects
bestiality porn yeah yeah sure like what
she it was something she was going to
send to her boyfriend because then she
had a whole bunch
the comments on the section was like
yeah she's got a lot of them each one of
them is like something different
some freaky [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] out there
dog's name was gator it was a [ __ ]
pit bull
was it i thought it was a rottweiler it
was a pit bull
i thought it was a rottweiler
that was a long time ago
it was one of those it was one of those
sites that
isn't it isn't all porn it's like some
of his porn is like sorry it's like
snuff and [ __ ] like that it's just like
it's like random crazy
the random like [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
video thing yeah and it's like you don't
exactly know like what you're getting
into like when you click on stuff and i
was just kind of like okay when it was
over she was laughing she couldn't
believe she did it
like what was it
oh my god
yeah there was a dude involved she was
sending it to some dude
well yeah so she was probably just like
yeah that'd be super hot if you go yeah
[ __ ] well evidently she's got she had
a bunch of them
she had a bunch of me they were all
different
so yeah so this girl like i said
she seems like she's not she's still
like kind of a little bit impaired but
she does a job she has a boyfriend
she can talk and um you know
it's sad because i feel like the media
is still kind of referred to hey
dog girl and she's kind of like gets a
little bit upset about that because
she's like hey um
hi i'm a person but you know and and she
had like a really shitty upbringing
which is why she ended up living with
the dogs in the first place and i
honestly can't say i blame her
uh because i probably would have gone
and hang out with the dogs as well
now there was a similar story to hers
and it also happened in russia and this
kid this was a boy though his name was
uh
yvonne mishikov and he was actually born
in 1992.
now this is the same kind of thing when
he was four years old uh
his mom and her boyfriend were both
drunks
because russia and um so he decided [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm out when he was four
he ran away um now this kid
ended up living with a ch uh a pack
of wild dogs in the street
not in the just in a kennel so he goes
out
and he figures out even though he's four
years old he figures out hey
if i give the dog some food then they'll
be nice to me so apparently that's what
he did like he would find some food and
give the dogs that and then they would
protect him um and eventually
according to him he worked his way up
the ranks and became like the alpha male
like you know the the pack leader
because he was human
now i don't know exactly how long i
think he'd been living with the dogs for
maybe like two years
uh you know just with a pack of dogs he
was uh
captured by the police in moscow in 1998
when he was six years old
and what they did the cops i guess like
he the kid had been reported because
they said hey
cops there's like this little kid little
naked kid
running around with the dogs and uh you
know might might want to look
into that so they left some bait out
like by a kitchen like the back of a
restaurant at the back of a restaurant
and they left some bait out for the dogs
and then like the dogs and the kid
came to get the food and that's how they
they captured them
now they said that he had actually
eluded the police several times prior to
this because like i said he'd been
reported
um and also the dogs were very very
protective of him
so whenever somebody tried to like grab
him the dogs would like freak out and
like start biting them and stuff
um so because now he was four
when he ran away so he could already
talk
um and he had lived with the dogs for
two years
so even though he had not like really
talked in all that time
after they captured him um
and kind of reintegrated him back into
society uh oh
it's mullet time yeah he was actually
able to uh
learn to speak again so like i said it's
kind of dependent upon
how young were they when they were gone
you know how long were they
in the you know living with animals blah
blah blah
you know what i'm saying yeah so yeah
that was like a similar story even
though these were street dogs this
wasn't like in the [ __ ]
going full-on prague rock you were so
like distracting
full-on [ __ ] guitars to hot molly
hatchet
yeah are you flirting with disaster full
flirting with disaster going full-on
[ __ ]
can't even kenny riders almost county
riders
it i feel like well kenny riders i feel
like you need a beard
yeah and that should here it'd be great
kind of
everybody had that hair on the 80s i
hate to say yeah it was worse than you
guys think
[Laughter]
every mainstream [ __ ] had this
goddamn mullet and nobody
like even questioned it it was like the
normal haircut you were able to play
normal everybody had it that's where you
were that was the haircut you were
supposed to have to fit in
yeah which is like funny to think about
anything anything
even cool people have that hair eating
anything that did deviated from this
you're a weird [ __ ] man what you
what's up with the hair
victor says i have a mullet right now
[ __ ] funny oh my god all right so
yeah so that was another uh dog kid so
now
this is the last case and this i i
apologize for ending on such a bummer
case but
now i want to talk about genie which is
the case that you were talking about
earlier
yeah man this is like this is
a [ __ ] heartbreaking story seriously
now yeah this girl like i said not so
much
i mean she's a feral child in the sense
that she didn't really have any human
interaction
uh for pretty much all of her childhood
she wasn't raised by animals or anything
like that unless you want to call her
dad an animal
she was leaving you have a good one
taylor swift have a good one
yeah go have dinner have a lovely
weekend you too
um yeah we're just gonna do one more
case and then we'll see how [ __ ] goes
so yeah for the first 13 years of her
life
uh she was basically isolated from human
contact uh she never learned to talk
um and because of the way that she was
imprisoned really um she was
really stunted she was really
malnourished they found her when she was
13 years old and they thought that she
was eight
years old that's how small she was damn
um
like i said it's kind of shitty because
when they discovered her
you know the scientific community was
like oh my god here's like you know a
case of a feral child they want to like
study her and stuff but
i don't know like i said there's there's
a lot of controversy still over
but what a deal was about what the deal
was about you know should they have
studied her
to that extent it's like how much how
much much ethics did they overstep it's
just
kind of like that kind of thing now her
real name wasn't janie uh
nobody you know they never released her
real name to the public
because they wanted to maintain some
semblance of privacy so that that's just
the name that they
gave her so now she was born
in 1957. her dad's name
was clark and her mom's name was
irene now irene uh
had been a she had run from the dust
bowl back in the 30s
uh and she had gone to los angeles and
that's where she met clark
now he was actually he had a pretty
[ __ ] up
uh childhood as well so
he had been um
raised in brothels pretty much uh i
don't know if his mom was a sex worker
something like that but he had
kind of gone from one brothel to another
um
and he had like this really really weird
relationship
with his mom kind of like a weird virgin
horror
love hate kind of thing going on almost
like an ed genie kind of
what is not quite that bad but you know
what i'm saying it was that kind of
thing
clark also [ __ ] hated children
um he didn't want them he didn't like
uh the noise that they made he didn't
like all the stress and the bother
um you know so him and irene though
now irene was much younger than him i
believe she was 20 years younger
um but when they married he was pretty
much i don't know if he told her this
ahead of time but he's like look i hate
kids and i don't want any
but i mean this was back in the [ __ ]
you know
30s 40s 50s you know women having birth
control that wasn't really a thing
um so whether you hated kids or not it
was just kind of like if you were having
sex with someone
eventually she was going to get pregnant
so that's just what happened so she did
um irene has a baby girl
and clark took the baby
and left the baby in the garage and the
baby froze to death
damn so this is what this is the family
situation that we're dealing with here
[ __ ] i mean mama do nothing well
the mom she um one she was much younger
than him
two he like abused the [ __ ] out of her
like he beat the crap out of her
uh manipulated her [ __ ] like that also
she
um had some problems she was like almost
blind
yeah when they married and then he beat
the [ __ ] out of her
so much that she almost went completely
blind later like from him beating the
[ __ ] out of her
right so so she didn't really have much
of a say
uh in it uh she kind of nutted up later
you know if you want to put it that way
but it was kind of too late at that
point
um and i don't blame her at all because
it sounded like she was in like a
horrible situation also
so yeah so they had a baby girl he was
just like yeah i'm just gonna stick this
out in the garage and the kid
uh froze to death so you know he's
probably thinking well put out here it's
making too much noise
that's pretty much that seems
essentially what what
yeah um so then they had a
second baby uh that one actually had a
congenital defect
uh and died not too long after
uh being born and then
um jeannie was born and then she also
had a brother
that was named john
now weirdly so clark the dad
obviously giant gaping [ __ ] right
yeah sounds like an idiot i said that he
had a weird thing with his mom
yeah so in 1958
his mom got killed in a car accident by
a drunk driver
and clark went way off the deep end
after that
um it just kind of seemed like
whatever semblance of sanity he was
holding on to prior to that happening
that just like at all went out the
[ __ ] window
so basically all right so
the mom irene like i said she was
legally blind
um and she got like her vision got worse
later on especially like from his abuse
and whatnot
now clark decided that when genie was
born
they don't think i mean nobody knows for
sure
because there aren't like any like
stringent medical records or anything
they don't think there was anything
really all that wrong with her
like not mentally not anything like that
there was a couple like physical things
but nothing that was
you know not uh you know nothing that
was insurmountable or nothing that was
like you know an intellectual issue or
anything like that she seemed like
normal that
uh in that way but
clark the dad became convinced that
jeannie was [ __ ]
um and basically that she was useless
so he decided and he told his family
meaning his wife and uh jeannie's
brother
no one is allowed to talk to her because
she is useless basically they strapped
her
to like you said like a toilet chair uh
port-a-potty types yeah and put her in a
room with the windows blacked out
and no one was allowed to talk to her
that's some weird [ __ ]
um and if you did talk to her he would
beat the [ __ ] out of you
so you know yeah he had some issues
there uh
yeah um she was either strapped to the
toilet chair
or in a cage right um
so you know also uh if she did anything
like
make noise he had this big uh
plank of wood that he would beat her
with
he also would do weird [ __ ] like he
would stand outside the door to her room
and growl at her like a dog
um for whatever reason but no no
yeah but no one would talk to her um
they're not entirely sure but it would
not uh shock me if this was true
uh but some people that have uh examined
her have speculated that maybe there was
some sexual abuse too which like i said
that would not surprise me because that
seems like right up this dude's alley
um and they think that because later on
like
after she was rescued she displayed
some uh inappropriate sexual behavior
toward
older men yeah so they think that maybe
he was raping that he was yeah
um like i said that sounds right about
in line with that type of dude
so you know that that wouldn't surprise
me that's weird [ __ ] dude
she lived like that for 13 years
no one talked to her she was in this
house
in this room and nobody talked to her so
it's like extended infancy with a bunch
of abuse
yes i don't think i don't think a a
consciousness could form during that
time
or you know what i mean i don't think a
consciousness could form i mean can you
understand because that's what i'm
saying a bunch of [ __ ] that has to
happen
yeah going through development of a
of an infant into a young kid into
you know what i mean into no i'm not
sure what would happen
you'd stay an animal i think yeah and
sadly it seems like that's kind of what
happened to her because
i mean she didn't have a chance right it
wouldn't develop
your brain wouldn't develop i mean like
i said she seemed like by all accounts
she seemed mentally
she seemed normal so what ended up
happening
okay so after 13 years what ended up
happening was that
jeannie's mom who was also um very
abused the brother was as well
not to the same extent as jeannie but
you know they got
abused as well so finally jeannie's mom
who was uh pretty much completely blind
at this point
um she was kind of like
she had been too afraid of her husband
to um
you know to intervene about the abuse
prior to this but finally
uh she decided [ __ ] this and i'm getting
out of here
so she left in 1970
taking genie with her now
she goes into the social services office
um i don't even think she was going
there to report the abuse she was just
going there because she like mistakenly
thought it was some other office like it
was something to do with her blindness
or whatever um
however she had genie with her and all
of the workers at the office noticed
jeannie was acting really really
weird like she would she couldn't really
walk she was kind of like hopping
and like so they thought it was kind of
strange so
uh they and she also was very very very
small for her age she was almost 14
years old and uh like i said they
thought she was
eight because she was very malnourished
and she was
so you know her growth was stunted
because she hadn't uh she'd been in a
cage and like strapped to a chair
so authorities were immediately called
in rightly so
uh and they opened up an abuse case
against uh the mom and the dad
um but as soon as clark the dad was
charged with child abuse
he blew his head oh it's his own head
off he knew
yeah he knew yeah which one good
riddance but two
it's kind of shitty that he never got
like [ __ ] punished for it he didn't
want to stand trial for that
[ __ ] well cause he knew maybe
he said apparently his suicide note said
the world will never understand yeah
no no that yeah no that no that's not
what it meant oh we understand
it means quite the opposite the world
will know what i did
that's what he means jesus [ __ ]
christ yeah so so at this point i mean
they decided they were going to drop the
charges against the mom because they
said clearly you know she was abused
also
she's blind she's disabled um and it's
like she didn't really have the
wherewithal or the you know resources to
deal with this [ __ ]
so they dropped the cases against the
the case against the mom but obviously
you know the dad was dead like i said
good riddance
so uh so jeannie was actually taken into
uh foster care and she became a ward of
the state
now when they took her in she knew a
couple of words
uh but that was about it so a lot of
like psychologists examined her
the quote at the time uh was that she
was quote the most profoundly damaged
child they had ever seen damn so
at this point as i said a lot of
psychologists have heard about the case
um you know they gave her a pseudonym
and they were like we need to study this
because we've never had
um you know a case in the field i guess
where a kid has lived for 13 years
without any human interaction and with
this level of
abuse she did she basically had never
been out of that room
uh she couldn't really she couldn't walk
she couldn't talk brained atrophied
yeah and all this other stuff so so they
needed they
felt like they wanted to study her uh so
they're you know all these like the
institute of mental health everything
like that they got all these like grants
and they studied her for four years uh
from 1971 to 1875
so basically it's kind of like
it's kind like i said this is a whole
gray area because the scientists were
like they were studying her yes which
makes her like a lab rat which is shitty
but a lot of the scientists at the same
time
became actually quite captivated by her
because they were kind of like
even though this was a very very damaged
child
um they almost they said she was
actually
quite um lovable in her way
um you know they said she was actually
quite
beautiful and she was just like you know
that so they could relate to her on that
human level even though
she had um you know she didn't have
the way she acted in a lot of ways like
i said was very inappropriate you know
she didn't really know how to do
anything that humans would do
so um they called her one of the
one of the uh scientists called the
behavior uh distasteful
which i guess that's a nice way of
putting it but yeah so you can i mean
you can imagine uh because of the way
she grew up
so so this four these four years
where she was being studied
as i said there's there might have been
some like breaches of ethics nothing
like
too egregious nobody's like saying
anybody was like you know
exploiting her necessarily but
it does kind of seem like
i don't know it like i said there's a
fine line between studying and
whatever so
you know linguists wanted to study
everything like that but there was this
whole team they were called the genie
team
and they wanted to
one of the main things they were
studying was like i said was she
developmentally disabled from birth
and then this caused the dad to like
because the dad seemed to believe that
there was something the matter with her
and that's why he abused her but
they were saying well maybe the abuse
caused that like maybe she was normal at
first because like i said
um you know obviously they found out
later that the dad had like
frozen their first kid to death
and then the second kid so like a couple
of their kids had some other problems
but
that didn't really mean you know i don't
know it was like a weird fun
kind of thing to like tease out i guess
now they said though that
even though um
she never did really learn language
um because they're you know they're
pretty sure she'd already gone through
puberty at this point and they're like
the language window had closed
which as i said that was kind of like
the theory at the time
and they said that seemed pretty true
but
on the other hand they did say actually
she was actually really curious when
they started
teaching her things she did actually
really seem to respond
and they said that while she was in the
care of the scientists
like in this uh you know under as a word
of the state
she didn't actually make a lot of
improvements she learned to she didn't
really learn to talk
but she learned how to communicate
she did learn some words like i said she
couldn't really learn any grammar or
anything like that but she could
get across her point and they said
actually she was
quite smart um she
kind of told stories and pictures like
you know what she wanted she was able to
put stories in sequence like things like
that so she wasn't
stupid i mean she wasn't dumb it's just
that she had never
experienced human language so that like
i said that window had passed
um she they said she could um you know
build things
out of you know they would give her
sticks or legos or whatever and she
could build like these complex
structures out of it
so it's like she wasn't you know she had
like high intelligence
so it's kind of like uh you know she
she could get her point across like i
said she could say something like
it's kind of like you know you know how
when they teach like gorillas like sign
language
and they just are kind of basically like
you know this that the other they don't
have like this complex but they get
their point across
that's kind of like what she talked
about um basically they were like
she would say something like applesauce
by store right yeah
like you know what that means right but
it's not like a whole sentence
so that's kind of like how she uh
communicated but they said that that
showed that she had
normal intelligence she hadn't just uh
learned to
you know put that across in a way that
everyone else could you know in in a
grammatically correct fashion so
apparently let me kind of like scroll
through i got like all these notes here
let me kind of go through here now so
what happened one of the main things
that caused like the kind of ethical
dilemma i guess this happened in 1971
so there was a l one of the language
teachers that was working with her was
named jean butler
and she got permission to bring genie
home with her
to try to kind of like socialize her
with the other kids and like the adults
and everything
now she was kind of um she
actually kind of said that jeannie was
kind of an interesting person because
she had like these weird
this is very strange and maybe you can
like have some insight on this and they
said this has happened a lot with feral
children that they've tried to
uh teach things they said a lot of them
have a fascination with
buckets or things that hold fluids
and they said jeannie did as well but
they said that's not the first
time that that's happened that they've
encountered that they said a lot some
for some reason like not all of them but
a significant portion of feral children
when they
try to resocialize them they're like
fascinated with things that hold
fluids glasses buckets that kind of
stuff my cousin wesley
the weirdest thing i remember that he
was fascinated by and this is when he
was like
five six seven around that period maybe
around eight and then by that time he'd
outgrown it
he was fascinated by the knot holes in
wood
oh that's interesting he didn't [ __ ]
climb around anything was wood and if
there was a knot hole there he'd circle
it
he put little numbers and symbols next
to it and then [ __ ]
maybe he thought it was like a like a
porthole to another dimension some
people were saying that maybe he thought
they were eyes
that could be also um but they don't
know what that was all about
and during that time he was also
interested in those thomas map books
and he would memorize maps yeah
okay so he would circle an eye and then
put like next to it like [ __ ] inner
interstate you know 95 i-95
and go there you know interstate 101.
well he spoke sign language at that time
and uh my mother said she was going to
diamond bar
and uh he goes and he goes that's far
if he said in english and he's like yeah
and my mom said that's a hundred miles
and he's like where are you going and
she [ __ ] told him the
the place in diamond bar where he was
going he goes no that's
not remember that exactly he said no
it's like 137 miles
he knew he knew how far that was yeah
because he knew everything about
california
and the in the interstate system of
california
how far everything was because he was
big into numbers
numbers and shapes well yeah like i said
that was a language he could do
well yes that's something like i said
there's usually they're like hyper
focused on that kind of stuff
yeah yeah yeah but for some reason this
fascination was not holes
that's weird he'd go inside of den when
he was a little kid
he would open up the [ __ ] drawers to
a [ __ ] chest of drawers or something
and throw all the [ __ ]
clothes out of it get in the drawer and
shut it
and you find him in there with in there
[ __ ] making noises and [ __ ] and
croaking croaking like a frog pointing
at knotholes
they were they were made out of the wood
on the inside of the damn
drawers that's crazy yeah he'd like to
be in there with the knot holes
it's just a trip man it's a [ __ ] trip
[Music]
deaf and autistic not that weird it's
not that weird i mean it's weird but
it's not that weird
for somebody there was some kind of
significance to [ __ ] knotholes
maps it meant something to him he liked
mad magazine
and especially the little books remember
they sold the little [ __ ] warner
brothers [ __ ] little
book soft cover mini novels from mad
magazine all the compilations
yeah spy versus yeah i had a couple of
those yeah he had all those because
there were numbers on him and he like
uh tried to think what else he he
[ __ ] would do was a trip
man it's weird growing up around him
california
[ __ ] experience all kinds of [ __ ]
from through the eyes of a [ __ ]
deaf and autistic kid you know who's the
same age as you he was just totally
alien to me i was shitty at math and he
would just look at me like i was [ __ ]
crazy that i couldn't
do this like advanced [ __ ] like
multiplying fractions well because it
was easy for him it was easy for him
he'd be
multiplying dividing and subtracting and
adding fractions
like lots of them he could do that and i
was just going like man i couldn't grasp
it and he's like you can't do it i was
like no i can't do it
and he's like you're dumb
because the hibit was all [ __ ]
obvious yeah that's obvious how to do it
so that's so fascinating though it's
like fascinating how how different
people's brains are you know
multiplication tables and [ __ ] yeah
remember you had to memorize the
multiplication
he memorized that instantly i never
really could i never really got my
multiplication tables
really yeah some of the simple you know
over time you know what i mean i know
but i had a problem memorizing him he
he would he learned that and like in a
day
and he was like a human calculator yeah
yeah well like i said they say that
about a lot of people
people with a particular kind of autism
there's lots of different kinds
and his dad was fascinated his dad was a
um a health inspector he was a
microbiologist
named larry is my uncle and
i i kind of had the feeling he was he
was embarrassed about wesley because he
wasn't normal
all right but he was amazed that he of
what he could do with math so he was
kept giving him math workbooks nobody
taught him how to do it he you could
give him
you could give him a math textbook and
quickly he would know everything in
there
and then they're giving him [ __ ]
college level early college level
[ __ ] math
he's doing it and he's like uh 11.
yeah doing that jet calculus i think he
had a problem with that
but um event trying to think about
geometry i think he knew about that too
you know pretty neat camp guy says they
say that they say that english is
considered fairly hard to learn for a
non-native speaker i've heard that as
well
i think it's largely because english is
so irregular
yeah very irregular um because it's
borrowed so much from other languages
um you know even [ __ ] man even native
english speakers have a problem
writing english i notice just saying
wesley could never really grasp it and
what was funny is that
a third grade word problem
he couldn't answer those but because it
was
the way it was laid out because it was
laid out he would go to me for those
which most people are the opposite like
if you lay something out like a word
problem
yeah they'll be able to do the math more
than if you lay it out just as a formula
because it's more like relatable he'd
take that workbook and go over to me and
he's like do you understand
he's like he'd point at it and i'd go
yeah yeah it's four
or yeah it's three and he would be
amazed that i could and
i could do that but that i couldn't do
the the other stuff and he just like
wow he'd make these weird crooked nose i
can't do it
rip it like a rivet he'd be looking at
me going rivet
that was how he kind of would like kind
of like a cat purr
yeah that was like his version of a cat
per and
he when he was tripping and kind of
content
he made this [ __ ] croaking noise in
his
throat like a like a like a frog yeah
ribbit
ribbit ribbit ribbit that's kind of
funny yeah he couldn't talk
well it's just kind of like and he
couldn't hear it yeah so it didn't it
didn't disturb him but that was just his
weird
way of being [ __ ] content he'd be
looking at me you answered that
you know i couldn't answer that but you
answered that that was the way
that was kind of the because we grew up
together so i was like one of the few
people he would look in the eye
yeah he didn't like to look adults in
the eye
yeah i get that yeah and then gill said
i think english is a simpler succinct
language
i've always kind of thought that as well
but no need for me too it points out too
many synonyms which yeah i get that too
and the thing about it is that we yeah
we have like a lot of different words
for like one concept and they don't mean
exactly the same thing like even they're
kind of synonyms
but in a way i like english like i
learned um i learned some spanish i took
spanish for two or three years i took
french for four years
and um one thing i always did not
i really disliked about the romance
languages
was that every noun was gendered and
it's just like
for them it's not a big deal because
that's just what they do and they just
like and they just remember
the gender of the noun along with the
noun so it's not like a big deal for
them
but for us that that whole concept was
is just like so strange
i learned that so young is just normal
yeah yeah
like i get it like i get if you just
grew up with that it's not weird to you
obviously but you can see why
native english speakers why it's weird
to us because we didn't grow up with
that concept because i'm like nouns
aren't girls or boys they're just nouns
each noun
yeah they are you're not used to it i
know
each noun has an article that is either
male or female
yeah and even place names
depending on how they're worded and how
that word
ends if it's a latin place name it's
gonna be male or female
if it's not a latin place name in other
words you know what i mean
like uh boston that's not a latin place
name right
then it's male or it's neutral and it
and you kind of have to use art to know
if it's neutral or male well because
german has
neuter as well not just male and female
so they have like almost like
but so does portuguese and spanish and
italian there's a neutral male and a
female
and you have to know when it's used and
it's a lot of it has to do with the
spelling of the word and how it
how it flows in the sentence um
but what i liked about like portuguese
is that it's very compact
you can have the noun
it's tense whether it's plural or
singular
and whether it's you know whether it's
past present or future you can say it
and whether and who it's directed to the
article you
we or they all in one word
means we would have gone
no no no i would have gone you know
so it's very compact i think that's what
yeah and you can it's very flowing and
um because of the way things are
gendered
ending in ao or e you can make a very
um pretty sentence with a lot of um
uh what's a good way to put it
it goes back they're all descending from
latin yeah
and the ancient romans were known for
their oratory skill
and and and and and their ability to
convince others
and the leadership qualities and it has
a lot to do with the way latin
languages are are are set up
they're very poetic and then there's a
bunch of double meanings
and stuff yeah that you can you can play
all these games with it
english is also kind of artistic but
it's very difficult
it's very different it's very basic
building blocks but
like they said there's a lot of weird
things like synonyms and double meanings
so we do it in a different way
yeah it doesn't quite sound as good it's
kind of like
the main german of all times if that's
you want to call them the main
[ __ ] main honky of course would have
been you know
uncle mustache adolf hitler he came out
and he was a great fan of the opera
and he said don't tell anybody
but really italian opera sounds better
than german opera
which that was some [ __ ] he told his
[ __ ] butler
and you're not what he wants to say that
in nazi germany but even hitler knew
that italian actually sounds better than
german when you sing it
in an opera well i can see that yeah and
english is like that too a lot of that
musical
[ __ ] and with the flowing poetry it
sounds better in latin
it makes more sense there's more there's
there's a greater dimension to it
in english i found honestly of all the
languages that i've and i'm not
fluent in any other languages although
i've tried to learn
several of them um italian was the
easiest
yeah because a lot of their words their
grammar
their grammatical structure isn't that
different from ours and a lot of the
words were not
maybe because i had already learned some
french and some italian and obviously
they're all from latin so
yeah i already kind of knew what a lot
of the words meant yeah um
but they they didn't have anything like
super complicated when i was taking
french
i felt one one of the hardest things
that i found in french not only the
whole gendered thing i got over that
but i didn't like all the different
forms of the verbs like we do that too
but it's not as extensive
you know what i'm saying portuguese is a
lot like
even though it came from spanish
supposedly
it was an offshoot of spanish it sounds
more like italian than romanian
i can hear romanian and to me it i can i
can understand it
i'm just and other now i don't think
portuguese people or romanians can but
as an american when i hear romanian i'm
like
yeah okay i understand what he said yeah
and it's because you're not biased
you know what i mean because i'm a
foreigner i heard it in there
you know italians
i can understand it almost completely
same italian spanish
they are surprisingly similar and like i
said i'm most familiar with french
because i took that the longest time i
took that for four years
so when i started learning italian a lot
of the words i already kind of i was
like i kind of figured what they meant
because the words are kind of similar
well portuguese you can understand
romanian and i don't think romanian is
[ __ ] direct
i think technically i don't think
romanian is [ __ ] related to
portuguese
directly remember we were watching that
vampire movie
yeah and that little girl was running
around talking and i says i don't know
what language it is but i understood
what she was saying
yeah uh well i could hear speeches of
chauchesku and understand what he's
talking about
and that's romanian that that's all came
from romance languages but yeah so i
mean if you learn one it's like
they're all kind of similar to like
learn the other something about the
rhythm and this
the rhythm of it and the sound of it and
the way the sentence is set up i'll go
that kind of rhymes with this sentence
in portuguese and
it is the same sentence now when now
when i was trying to learn to speak
welsh that was a different uh that was a
different issue
now welsh it grammatically it's
structured very similar to english which
i've
appreciated because you know in french
the romance languages they tend to
uh you know they tend to they don't have
you know in english you have like
adjective noun whereas like in the
romance languages you tend to have like
the noun before the adjective uh which
always kind of threw me off
welsh is kind of structured like english
in that way
but and i think i mentioned this before
one of the things that threw me off is
that the letters themselves
do not have the same sound remotely that
they have in english
so when you see like for example a w
or a u in welsh it is not pronounced
remotely the same as what it's
pronounced like in english which
really really threw me dj maniac here's
german inside of portuguese
it's because there's a lot of there's a
lot of latin influence
in german they have the same kind of
articles
they have gendered gendered articles and
nouns
uh the grammar is very similar so
i hear german i don't really understand
a lot of it but
if i see it written i can i can see
the the latin structure of it yeah
that's that's all
victor says it's weird how portuguese
speakers can understand spanish pretty
easily
not the other way around but not the
other way around no yeah and it's
because portuguese has so many italian
and french words in it
yeah like in portuguese there's going to
be an italian version of that word or
french version of that word
and so it's portuguese has a bigger
bigger vocabulary than than spanish
so because it's i don't know it's just
that more is acceptable in portuguese
for some reason the history of the
language
that's interesting yeah although as far
as i know i don't know
like as far as number of words and
vocabulary but i do know that the
english dictionary is
way bigger than pretty much any other
okay well look
you know what the word deer is right
yeah that's a german word for that
[ __ ]
animal yeah venison is the same animal
but that's the french version of it
yeah okay it's because culinarily
our language our food words are based
upon our french
trainings yeah so you know what i'm
talking about so venison
you recognize that also as deer yeah
portuguese is like that
okay yeah right i get it zach says the
only thing in english i still struggle
with is when the proper use of
punctuation is in certain things
i feel like a lot of people have that i
never really had an
issue with grammar punctuation anything
like that and i'm not really sure why
that is i don't know if it's just
because i'm a grammar dork
or because i started reading really
early and i read a lot when i was a
little kid
so i saw english
uh properly the way it was like
punctuated and everything like that so i
got used to
seeing it done correctly so when i
eventually got to school
and they were teaching us english and
punctuation it all just came to second
nature because i'd already seen it
like done correctly here's another
example pig
hog swine and pork
they all mean the same thing but pork is
a latin or
it's like a french version swine hog and
pig or germanic versions of those words
okay well imagine portuguese is like
that too for every one word there's
more french more italian more german
versions of those words so it allows you
to understand other languages now
spanish may not be like that
they may not have swine and hog
you know what i mean yeah that'd be a
good example of you
for you yeah camp guys saying the
elements of style is a great english
writing tips book indeed it is yeah good
old strunk and white i have a copy of it
back there somewhere it might be in the
closet there
uh but yeah that's it's a very slim very
easy to understand book of like english
grammar rules
uh you know i anybody that's gonna go
into writing for a career i would
recommend that they read that because
it's
tells y'all it lays all the [ __ ] out and
it's like really really easy so let me
finish up this case really really quick
um so as i said this is the case so okay
so one of the uh people that was on the
team
gene butler she was a language teacher
and she
sort of adopted jeannie for a while hey
can i take her back to my house and work
with her which seemed fine you know for
socialization
issues and [ __ ] like that like i said
she realized that
genie was obsessed with buckets and
other things that held fluids
however um this is going great
and then all of a sudden for whatever
reason i'm not saying this wasn't true i
don't know
but the woman says oh uh
she got rubella and so
me and jeannie need to be quarantined
and everyone was like okay fine because
that's contagious
but then after a while she seemed to
like not want to let anybody have access
to jeannie anymore um and she started
turning away like the other doctors
uh you know saying oh you're you know
you're getting too much
to get into uh you know too much
scrutiny everything like that
so she tried to basically foster
genie and the other doctors didn't like
it
so then the other doctors started saying
that she was exploiting genie
and then they their story was and like i
said i don't know if this is the case
their story was she wanted to get famous
just like
anne sullivan did with helen keller
right like you know the
the woman that taught helen keller how
to speak or how to understand things
so it's like she kind of thought that
she was going to get famous doing that i
don't know that's what the other doctors
accused her of
um so they kind of accused her of
essentially not really kidnapping her
but kind of like keeping her away from
the doctors so she could get all the
glory i don't know if that was true or
not but that's what they accused her of
so there was that whole thing but they
eventually got her
uh away from that woman and then she
went to live with another therapist
named david wrigler and his family who
was also on the team
uh but this worked out a lot better and
they actually just kind of
you know worked with her and she had a
family it was like a living in a foster
family
and that seemed fine so basically
uh but the other he kind of let the
other psychologists come like and have
access to her
uh and things like that uh to for their
studies and whatnot so it was a book
written about her and [ __ ] like that
and um she seemed to be doing okay um
she didn't like i said she didn't learn
to talk but she got very good at
communicating like non-verbally
so that everybody could like kind of
figure out what she was uh talking about
now the uh funding for the study ended
in 1975 at which point jeannie went
back to live with her mom now in 1979
her mom sued uh the hospital
and all of the individual caregivers uh
you know including all the scientists
that have been on the genie team
saying that they had exploited genie
this suit was settled out of court i
believe in 1984
and jeannie was no longer given access
or the psychologists were no longer
given access to her after that
point now jeannie then went into
foster care and sadly
when she went back into foster care all
of the progress that had been made with
her between 1971 and 1975 as far as
teaching her to communicate and stuff uh
regressed
so uh that was all so sad then she went
from foster home to foster home
and several of these were again sadly
abusive
uh so you know she was beaten whatnot
and regressed
even further and sadly never
got back all of the progress she had
made while she was working with all the
psychologists
uh because she had been put in a bunch
of abusive environments
yeah so the mom [ __ ] her again pretty
much yeah
i mean like i said i don't want to blame
the mom too much because the mom was a
victim as well
but it probably you know is it great for
her to be the subject of a study
no but she seemed to be get help though
she seemed to be doing better right
under
the psychologist's care than she was
somebody earlier on says they don't need
to be studying they need to be helping
her
no i think they were helping that is the
same i think they were helping
right because the only way you're going
to get help is by them studying and
see what the problem is and then they're
building on top of that it's part of the
therapy
you can't just help a person if you
don't know what's wrong yeah
you know because they don't know what
they're dealing with
yeah and the thing about it sometimes
human mind is complicated
you have to figure out what what the
person lacks and there's no
treatment for this there's no treatment
but is there
some course you take to tell you how to
put a human mind back together
no no it has to be done yeah i mean she
has to be
you have to work with her every day and
see what yeah
so you have to have people that are
willing to
you know and maybe even if it's in their
own self-interest but people that are
willing to work with her
every day right to figure out like
what's the best way to help someone like
what's this
situation i'm gonna tell you just
[ __ ]
everything that i've seen growing up
with my [ __ ] cousin and [ __ ]
they couldn't help her i don't think i
think once you pass a cert like you said
passing that window
that's about it i mean she was 13 when
they found her that's about it
because
not allowing the [ __ ] mind to unfold
naturally in a [ __ ] environment that
you were
in a family environment and because you
were evolved to unfold naturally in a
family environment
in the world interacting with things
denying a person that is
is equivalent to brain damage yeah
that's exactly what it is
so and to reverse the brain damage like
that
as the body's growing nah i don't think
so
well that's what i mean well they found
that like just there hasn't been like
that many cases of this but in most of
the cases it can't be done
you might be able to improve them a
little bit but you'll never have
they have they'll have an intelligence
but it won't be like a normal human
intelligence
well yeah i mean particularly as regards
to language and communication they just
never
certain basic things that you're going
to learn at certain times that time
passed so you'll never really learn that
yeah and it's
it's shitty that's the foundation that
the mind is built upon
because it wasn't her fault it was just
there i mean her dad was a piece of [ __ ]
yeah and ruined her whole entire life he
killed himself though so [ __ ]
i mean she might have had she grown up
in like a normal family she
probably would have like had a normal
happy life you know what i mean
it was just because that dude was such a
piece of [ __ ] and yes he was abused as
well
but yeah it doesn't matter that's what i
mean he he ruined her whole entire life
her whole entire life was ruined because
of that and like
so like i said the last anyone's really
heard of her
her mom died in 2003 um
and as far as they know i think they the
last time they did an interview and they
took photographs of her was in 2008
and at that point she was in uh she you
know she's in a care home in
los angeles and as far as i know she's
still there
um and apparently she's being well taken
care of like i said she never
as far as anyone knows she never did
like regain all the progress that they
made with her back in the 70s
um you know because she went through
more abuse
later on after the uh you know her mom
took her away from the scientists
so there was that whole issue which is
just like
it this is a shitty story because it
didn't have to happen you know what i
mean it just didn't have to happen
and um you know like i said she could
have just she could have been a normal
kid
but it's just yeah i'm getting big yeah
i'm getting big i'll get a little bit
bigger
gotta lose weight too burning that fat
off burning that fat burning fat off a
couple more months you guys will see it
about [ __ ] um
somewhere between 20 and 18 body fat
when you get down to 15 you're doing
good [ __ ] good but that's good that
might be a month or so away
yeah we'll see how yeah we'll see how it
goes yeah so this is about it
so that yeah that was the last case i
just want i'm sorry to like end
on a bummer note like that but it's like
i did actually want to talk about her
because she's kind of one of the most
famous
quote unquote feral child cases i don't
think much could have been done for her
though i'm just
saying well that's what i'm saying it's
like by the time they found her
it was way too late which like i said
that sucks yep
but as i said that just goes to show man
you have kids don't [ __ ] them up yeah
you really gotta
and that was on the back of that dude
not wanting to admit he was wrong
that's what i think yeah i think he
thought there was something wrong with
her
because he didn't want the kid in the
house and he's like yeah there's
something wrong with this kid and then
his time went on i think he
realized he was he was hurting that kid
and
when he got busted he says [ __ ] it he
shot himself yeah they'll never
understand no they will understand
that's why everyone understands everyone
understands that you like suck as a
human being
you know what i mean yeah girls mental
and physical growth
i don't honestly i don't know i wasn't
there i don't think there's anything
wrong with that little girl
and probably not nothing mental probably
no i don't think there was
no um you know what i mean well and like
i said he had a history of it he like
[ __ ] neglected yeah what the [ __ ] man
jesus christ
it's just like [ __ ] yeah pretty much
all right i want to thank you guys go
ahead and [ __ ] hit that like button
share and subscribe if you can thank you
for the super chats today
uh but me and jenny got a [ __ ] roll
it was good to see you guys
and we will [ __ ] be back when sunday
be back sunday it's friday right yes
right we'll be back sunday afternoon
excited we'll see you guys
somebody asked us to do a show about
richard donner because he just
passed away yeah you know he did
superman and all that kind of stuff yeah
yeah yeah
so uh maybe maybe we can do that on
sunday i'll put something together
tomorrow
we'll see how it goes all right all
right so thank you everybody for
dropping by
like share subscribe all that kind of
stuff that tom already said yeah and we
will see you guys on
sunday afternoon bye